foreign
good morning to all and uh it's Friday
tomorrow
so Saturday and Sunday are fortunately
in front of us and of course this this
committee doesn't have any work on
Monday either so we need that break I I
understand I need that break
um so although I will be here on Monday
so but at any rate uh before we go
anywhere today I like to have us all
stand
and take a moment of silence today is
international Holocaust day
and reflecting on that awful genocide
which occurred in World War II
um where we had over 6 million Jews
slaughtered and awful and also reflect
on genocide that's currently occurring
in this world it's it's replicated in
many continents right now so let's all
stand take a moment of silence and try
to remember
thank you
once again this is a good reason for us
having that in our adequacy formula as
one of the substantial criteria in which
we study in our schools on the social
studies Etc Holocaust and genocide is
mentioned so that's a good thing that we
do and hopefully our schools are
remembering the same today
so going on with today I want to
announce to the committee that on
Tuesday we do have some bills which
we've noted we have a work session on I
was in communication with HHS and doe
for a good party yesterday we will have
that work session dealing with those
bills and following that work session we
will go into a caucus both parties will
go into a caucus so there will be a a
brief caucus following that before you
start executing bills remember if you
are not going to be here on a day in
which bills are exact let your let your
leader of your party know that so that
they can find a replacement for you here
on the committee
thank you let's go ahead now and open up
the first bill for today in the first
bill
is 572 relative eligibility for free
School meals so five seven two represent
Hall you're already at the chair ready
to go welcome good morning good morning
chairman LED and my theme colleagues on
the education committee
the title of House Bill 572 is relative
to the eligibility for free School meals
this bill is a product of a great deal
of interim study work a committee on
which I served with my fellow colleagues
Representatives Ford Ellison Lucas and
Woodcock and which was led passionately
by The Honorable Sue Mullen who will be
testifying today these meetings included
discussions on universal food bills
three-tiered systems of free and reduced
lunch and ones with a single eligibility
cap approach which this bill today
represents the intent of this bill is
twofold one to help support low to
Middle income families by raising the
eligibility cap for free School meals to
300 percent of poverty and as
importantly two to cast the broader net
beyond the federal guidelines to capture
more students and to ensure that as many
as possible receive at least one
preferably two nutritious meals per day
with the additional cost paid for by the
state
food is one of the basic necessities of
life and food insecurity puts tremendous
stress on families
it only takes a trip to the grocery
store to know that food price inflation
is increasing significantly families are
feeling the strain of those increases as
well as the cost of gas housing and
utilities
in preparing for this bill I researched
the 2023 federal poverty guidelines for
different sized households and how much
districts actually charge for School
meals
with the eligibility cap set at 300
percent a family of four would be
eligible if their income was no more
than ninety thousand dollars
as for the cost of meals hopkinton's
website indicates it charges nothing for
student meals involved where I live and
talk for 32 years breakfast cost two
dollars and lunch costs three dollars I
found the same lunch prices in the
goldfin schools in the North country
which I and my 13 siblings attended
I remember the elementary school
cafeteria lady saying to me one day as I
handed her my 25 cents
I just don't understand why your parents
don't apply for free and reduced lunch
imagine saying that to an 18 year old
eight-year-old today
as a side note I found it interesting
that today 60 years later my parents
with a household of 16 two kids in
college nine in public schools and three
babies at home would be considered
living at a level of poverty if they had
an income of 90 000 per year and they
would be paying more than 500 a month
for school lunches without assistance
just a side note the importance of food
in the child's education is quite
obvious as we've heard repeatedly on
this committee School meals played a
critical role in student health
well-being and academic success success
a healthy diet can give a child the
energy to think work and play
we recently heard the associate
executive director of New Hampshire
school administrators Association
testified that the toughest part of his
job as a school superintendent was
having to make the decision to cancel
school knowing that some kids would not
get a meal that day
when I was seeking co-sponsors for this
bill back in December my first recruit
was representative Dr cascadden when I
shared the intent of the bill and
inquired if she would be a co-sponsor
she immediately asked well who's going
to pay for it
at the time I answered I don't know
where is that money going to come from
the general fund the education trust
fund some other source of Revenue I
still don't know exactly but in
searching for answers I'm reminded of
what representative Miler shared with us
at the beginning beginning of this
session
we need to understand that our job on
the education committee is to create
policy which meets the educational needs
of students and to let Finance decide if
and how it will be funded and that's why
I'm here today introducing this bill on
feeding hungry kids
you will see on the fiscal note which um
the doe will speak to after me
information provided by the DOA doe
indicates that all costs are
indeterminable at this time
as I stated earlier the intent of this
bill is for the state to cover the cost
associated with the increase in the cap
as well as Staffing and administration
of the program to develop a new process
for eligibility determinations
offering free lunches for all students
regardless of income as well as the case
during the pandemic would be ideal our
existing system of having three
categories of pricing results in
burdensome application processes
oftentimes stigmatizes students who
receive free or reduced meals and can
cause families to carry lunch death
some states have taken their own action
and have passed Universal meals
legislation others have legislation
pending in state houses
I urge you to support HB 572 which the
directs the state to provide funding to
pay the difference between the federal
requirement for a free reduced breakfast
and or lunch and the full price for each
meal at no cost to students who fall
under the 300 eligibility cap
I trust that we can all agree that no
student should regularly go to school
hungry and HP 572 is a good first step
to help solve this problem
I understand that it might be a
challenge for the doe to work it all out
but I would argue that a far greater
challenge is on the hungry children
and with that I will take any questions
The Honorable Sue Mullen has assured me
that she is at the ready to answer any
questions you might have so feel free to
wait to ask her those questions and
there are others behind me as well thank
you
oh that's a good one yeah right I mean
Sue monster ejection button right boom
that's right she said I have your back
thank you very much other questions for
representative Hall
yes your question representative
cardelli thank you thank you
representative Paul
um uh you said that this bill was a
first step what's the second step
Universal would be the second step but
there are other there could be steps in
between as well I don't know amendments
I you know
thank you
I have a question is the first step
really that we get the Medicaid direct
Bill satisfied yes and then move into
this type of uh
yeah that would be a good thing yeah
thank you
yes represent Belcher oh I was hoping
you weren't going to ask a question
The Honorable
I appreciate that
um you brought up a couple very
important points you brought up costs
but I I don't want to talk about costs I
want to ask about nutrition
um obviously this is a very important
issue
uh we've heard testimony in the last
week for multiple students attending
various schools in the state that their
food options are according to them quite
bad
um recently there's been investigative
journalism looking at the USDA
guidelines that shows some schools are
purchasing meals that are actually
skipped over from fast food places
because they're not up to their
standards and we have a child obesity
crisis so what assurances do we have
that children are actually receiving
nutritious meals
well a good start would be the farm to
school bill right I mean I mean I I mean
I can't assure anything but
um I totally agree the nutritious meals
need to be offered
um
as much as I grew up in a poor family
I'm going to say hindsight I didn't know
it at the time but living on a farm
hindsight I was the best dead kid in
town uh you know but I didn't realize
that until I was an adult and I was like
wow like there were no potato chips and
soda no it was meat and potatoes
thank you for answering my question
I know so you understand that speaker is
terrible
um
you had said you were hoping you were
your intent is that the state will pay
that but I don't see that actually in
your bill as written and as written I'm
afraid that the school districts are
going to feel that they have to take on
that extra
do you have are you willing to do an
amendment that makes that clear
absolutely I would expect that um there
will be an amendment thank you
further questions not seeing any thank
you very much oh my gosh
honorable Sue Mullins
from Bedford
thank you so much
good morning and thank you chairman Ladd
for your welcome
I would thank representative hall for
involving me this morning but I'm not so
sure that that wasn't a setup so uh
that's about you're exactly right uh
good morning last week I testified
before you and offered general
information from the study committee on
house bill 1229 which met last session
to consider School meals
today I would like to address
representative Hall's proposal to alter
the eligibility threshold for free and
reduced meals from the federal guideline
of 185 percent of poverty level to 300
percent
for those of you that are not familiar
with those guidelines uh there are
there's paperwork coming at you that has
the various levels per
number of family members and you should
be receiving that soon
the legislative intent of this bill is
to widen the safety net that we are
using to support hungry kids
during our study committee time we heard
from constituents who expressed concern
that families who did not meet the
eligibility requirements were in fact
struggling to feed Folks at home
these are families who earned more than
185 percent of the poverty guidelines
but not enough to meet the soaring costs
of things like housing and other
Associated fees of raising a family
through no fault of their own we have
students who eat the bulk of their meals
at school and this bill supposes that we
have an opportunity to reach more of
them
our current statute RSA 189 11a
already authorizes the State Board of
Education to establish the eligibility
criteria that is different from the
federal government it reads
the State Board of Education shall
ensure compliance with this section and
shall establish minimum nutritional
standards
for each meal as well as income
guidelines set for the family size used
in determining eligibility for free and
reduced price meals
so in the spirit of trying to think
outside the box
House Bill 572 proposes to raise the
threshold to 300 percent of the federal
poverty level
I have provided you with a copy of those
guidelines as I mentioned
the committee recognized that this would
represent a considerable amount of
effort on the part of the state board
and the Department of Education as rules
and procedures would need to be
developed regarding the application
process the allocation of funds and how
to interface these new New Hampshire
standards with current federal standards
that require a federal free and reduced
amount of data for dollars
the financial note on this on this bill
acknowledges some of that but the actual
cost of the program remains
indeterminable
in the past that has meant the kiss of
death
the can't instead of the can but I am
quite certain that with due diligence a
ballpark figure can and should be
determined
I am asking the committee to consider
the need the effective date the
necessary funding and the steps we need
to take to make childhood hunger a
non-issue in New Hampshire
other states have initiated uh measures
ranging from paying for new meals
program staff to providing lunches for
everyone I have included the link to the
most recent information from the food
resource and action center Below in the
copy of my statements that you have
it's easy to do something because we
have done almost nothing to expand the
opportunity to feed our hungry kids
as I said last week it's time to shift
our Paradigm away from what we can't do
to what we can do it's a
well-established fact that hunger
negatively impacts learning I'm hopeful
that we will be able to demonstrate our
learning by extending a hand up to our
most precious resources I thank you for
listening to me and ask that you support
House Bill 572 and uh with trepidation I
will take questions thank you very much
other questions from the committee yes
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair
I I just wanted to speak briefly or
question the um the issue of nutrition
again because it does in fact in the
bill say that the State Board of
Education shall ensure compliance and
she'll establish minimum nutritional
standards
and I love that however is it not a bit
misleading because if we accept federal
dollars in this program USDA program are
we not effectively seeding our state
authority to the federal government and
are we not forced to accept the USDA
guidelines for nutrition
um
question representative Belcher uh no
one has probably mentioned to you that I
am not an attorney
though they would like to put me in a
variety of different roles I I can't
answer to the legality and that cocked
eyebrow at you I want to clarify was
because I was joining with you on the
idea that the State Board of Education
has the authority to set those
nutritious standards okay thank you
you're welcome
representative Damon are Damon do you
have your hand up earlier
oh well you're good you're gonna test
that represent uh Tanner
thank you and thank you for coming this
morning
um those standards
are minimum standards is that correct
the the nutritional standards so uh any
school or
um any vendor that's hired by the school
to provide lunches can go above those
minimum standards most definitely those
are minimum standards yes
I already asked one
um I've got a question for you yes
during the past year or so we had all
children due to the pandemic receiving
meals were do you know of any
information that might be available
saying that even though they were
offered a school meal a family or
families chose to provide their own
meals in other words during that did
everybody just start joining on or were
there some that maybe stayed out I don't
have the numbers on that uh Kelly Rambo
from the doe is is behind behind me
um I think the closest we could come to
that would be the total number of
students enrolled and the total number
of meals served
so I would ask her for the data on that
representative
um but I think that that's yeah thank
you further further questions
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just a real brief
follow-up on the on the uh question that
these are minimum standards from the
USDA that we could theoretically exceed
uh from the state can you walk me
through if the USDA guidelines mandate
say 50 of calories come from
carbohydrates and no more than 10 come
from fats what would it look like for us
to exceed those standards
first of all the state of New Hampshire
already exceeds Federal standards in
many areas special education being one
of them so I would refer to that as an
example of of a case in which New
Hampshire actually does better by its
students than the federal minimum
I I would think that exceeding the
federal standards would have to do with
uh you know lower salt
perhaps making sure those carbohydrates
are complex carbohydrates uh it would be
the definition I I would think of what
the minimum indicates and then making
the meals healthier than that or adding
things to
so maybe monitoring
um the quality of dairy products the
amount of sugar in individual things you
know increasing some lowering others
Nancy Vaughn from the American Heart
Association is also in the audience
today and she actually is somebody who
is much more knowledgeable about the
specifics of the USDA regulations so I
would encourage you to direct that
question to her when she when she's at
the moment thank you yeah
are there further questions of honorable
sumon
yes representative cascadden thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
Mullen
um I know you worked on this committee a
whole year I believe right in trying to
raise that threshold right well we uh
the study committee actually convened
after the end of the session so it was
through the summer and fall okay and I
my question is and I don't know if you
have the this answer or maybe some
somebody else does
um but the car seat Institute had
conducted a significant study on food
insecurity among families and children
in the state I don't know if you're
familiar with that maybe still on their
website but I can't remember what that
percentage was other than I know koas
County was up the roof I mean kids were
just struggling for for food and I think
that would be a great data point
um
yeah I'm not sure whether or not new
Hunger New Hampshire hunger Solutions is
with us this morning but they were a
pivotal point of information for us in
sort of uh digging deeper into into New
Hampshire uh we were more looking at the
issue more globally representative than
than Target specific but that would
certainly be something that uh would be
worthwhile to look at in the future yeah
County County if that can be found thank
you further questions not seeing you
thank you very much uh representative
lad just
um one one final thing to say to you
before uh I I leave this microphone I
wish I could tell you this would be the
last time that you'll see me this year
but it probably won't be but um I I just
want to reiterate for the committee
again that hunger childhood hunger in
New Hampshire is not neither a Democrat
nor a republican issue it is a
bipartisan issue that affects children
of all all types of and sizes of
families and I would hope that this
represents the type of topic that we can
reach across the aisle over and come up
with some common solution that everybody
can live with thank you you're welcome
I'd like to ask New Hampshire HHS
are they here today Jessica
foreign
good morning good morning representative
plaid in the education committee
um so I wanted to start off today with
some facts from New Hampshire hunger
Solutions around this bill
um and then I also have a couple pieces
of testimony to share with you
um which I've also included in the
documents that we're passing around
um so House Bill 572 aims to increase
the income eligibility for free and
reduced School meals to 300 percent of
the poverty level and eliminate the
reduced price category for school
lunches in order to provide more
students with access to nutritious food
increasing kindergarten through 12th
grade student eligibility for free and
reduced meals to 300 of poverty will
ensure that more children have access to
the nutrition that they need to reach
their full potential
and you'll see linked some information
from Frac where you can get more
information about the studies that have
been done on this
um
so with that being said Studies have
shown that access to nutrition meals
nutritious meals improve student health
both mental and physical academic
performance and overall success reducing
poor rates of reducing rates of poor
health by at least 29 and rates of
obesity by at least 17 based on
estimates used in National Data
House Bill 572 provides greater
stability for those in need allowing
them to focus more on their studies and
less about worrying about where their
next meal will come will come from and
that is something we're hearing from the
Food Service directors we work with
where kids are going to school crying
because they no longer have access to
that free meal their parents either have
not been able to complete the form don't
know that the form is something they
have to complete because of the pandemic
waivers
um so there's a variety of reasons why
sometimes those forms aren't being
completed
um currently eligibility for free and
reduced meals it's set at 130 and 185
percent of poverty 130 percent for free
and 185 percent for reduced
leaving a large portion of students who
are financially vulnerable without
access to meals the current median rent
for a two-bedroom apartment in New
Hampshire is nineteen thousand and eight
dollars per year that's the median I'm
saying that that's pretty generous
considering I just moved my
um newly graduated daughter into her
first apartment at two thousand dollars
a month for a one bedroom
um
and working full-time at minimum wage is
fifteen thousand and eighty dollars per
year that means that even with two
adults working full-time minimum wage
jobs they would not make enough to meet
the basic needs for their family the
living wage for two adults and one child
in New Hampshire is sixty five thousand
dollars five sixty five thousand five
hundred and seventy seven dollars and
even with two adults working it
increases to seventy seven thousand one
hundred and ninety five dollars due to
child care costs the
um federal poverty poverty line for a
family of three in 2023 is twenty four
thousand eight hundred and sixty dollars
meaning that three hundred percent of
the poverty level would be seventy four
thousand five hundred and eighty dollars
and on the third page of what I handed
out is the chart that also um
represented honorable Mullen handed out
as well
um and just to reiterate the cost of
School meals for one child it's about 90
dollars a month but
um for a family that has more than one
child that price increases and so for a
family with three children it would be
two hundred and seventy dollars a month
and that's on the average price of meals
um around the state each school district
is just slightly different
this legislation would also provide a
much needed boost to the economy as it
would create jobs in the food service
industry and provide additional support
for grocery stores and Farmers we know
that for every dollar spent in school
meals there's a two dollar return on
investment to the local community and
that comes from the Rockefeller
Foundation as far as where that data
point comes from
um it would also save staff time effort
along Food Service directors to focus on
kids nutrition rather than managing
different categories of School meals and
I can speak to a little bit more of some
testimony from a food service director
in just a second
um this bill is in line with the
universal School meals laws passed by
States like Maine from and Vermont and
will help to ensure that students have
access to nutritious food regardless of
their family's income level and I can
attest that through our work with the
food research and action center who is
their National anti-hunger Advocate that
many states around the country are
passing similar bills to this which
allow more kids to eat at school
um so I want to just take a minute if
it's okay to read from one of our food
service directors
several families ask questions regarding
the eligibility guidelines the
guidelines have not adjusted enough to
allow for the rates of inflation we're
experiencing right now many are asking
why don't they take into account my
expenses my expenses have increased so
much in the past couple of years but my
pay has not increased to meet the
demands of my paycheck
many families are left in a void that
makes it difficult to pay for lunches
and making too much to qualify for free
and reduced meals our families are
struggling due to the increases of
utilities and groceries free and reduced
applications are based on Gross and not
met many families are paying for
insurance and having mandatory
retirement deductions after so many
hours of work it's a real struggle for
some families students would rather have
a hot lunch than a bag lunch from home
it may also be the only hot meal or meal
they receive in our district we have
many grandparents as Guardians due to
substance use and incarceration their
social security income was not designed
to raise a family on I believe we need
to be taking care of our students in our
country in order for them to grow and
learn it's an investment in the future
of our country every child needs
consistency and Security in their life
not food insecurity students were
participating in hot nutritional
breakfast
um and now with needing to pay our
account has gone down we need to change
how this program works to meet the needs
of all students and this food service
director says thank you for allowing me
to have a voice
thank you very much are there questions
from Health and Human for Health and
Human Services
I have a question okay um
you mentioned that we have families out
there which we all know that are dealing
with a single parent in substance abuse
an incarceration do you have a handle on
where we're going in terms of the
statistics on this whether that is
increasing from where we have been
God is not our expert area of expertise
but it is something that school
districts are seeing that more and more
grandparents are raising
um children their grandchildren due to
various
um situations we're looking at one
okay other questions represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um
am I am I correct in Remembering did we
recently have testimony from a high
school student affiliated with the
organization on the farm to school bill
she was I believe
um in representing the um scan
organization save the children Action
Network okay
um well if I may
um
regardless we heard from that student
that she testified that the quality of
the foods offered in her school were
indeed quite bad according to her
I'm trying to understand
if if this so there's an incentive
structure that creates that situation
and I'm trying to understand does this
bill expanding this program
seek to reinforce does that reinforce
that incentive structure that leads to
these as she testified poor quality
foods rather than moving toward better
quality foods in schools
um so as far as nutritional standards
for the schools I will leave that to the
Department of Education to answer but
what I can say is that from our
conversations with food service
directors many of them are running in
school debt right now which means that
ins because families are unable to pay
for the school meals that they have that
means that those programs are running in
the red
um when you think about going to a
restaurant because a lot of times the
food service programs are separate
budgets from the actual School District
so those monies have to come from the
sale of food if families aren't able to
afford to feed their children or their
children are eating and not able to pay
that means that these programs are
running in debt there's also been huge
increases in the cost of food somebody
was just telling me the other day in
order to serve a serving of celery and
meet the federal standards that it's
almost 40 cents for that serving of
celery per student now if that happens
to be a lunch price that's 40 cents of
three dollars that doesn't give into the
other components nor does it give in to
the labor costs that are accrued in
order to feed that one student
um I think that you know nutrition
standards are very important and even
with where they are based on the minimum
guidelines by the federal government the
numbers that you're seeing that we've
presented here for
um improved Health outcomes and improved
rates of obesity still stand there's
still an increase with the federal with
where the guidelines are now so an
improvement in that would be even better
right and so that means it's a minimum
and as to the point of Representative
health or they can always do better
thank you thank you represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair thanks for
joining us today from from New Hampshire
hunger Solutions right thank you and and
I'm just uh just sort of a follow-on to
representative belcher's question when
it comes to the the you know comments
that this committee and others have
heard with respect to subjective you
know um comments about quality of food
um uh I was wondering if you could
comment a little bit about the like as
you were just doing the the objective
standard for quality of food and how
that may relate to
um not having a breakfast or lunch at
all
so students not eating because they
don't so let me put in another one okay
would it would it uh
would it be would a student be better
off having a meal that meets the the
objective standards set by the state or
federal government compared to not
having a meal at all
absolutely thank you absolutely thank
you further questions
thank you very much
oh did you is there another question I
think
yes go ahead
thank you thank you Mr chair
um I missed which piece of data you said
was
um you received from the Rockefeller
foundation for every dollar spent in
school meals there's a two dollar return
on investment
thank you
and I will just say because we do
support a lot of breakfast
um legislation as well that we know that
um we miss about 78. 100 students a day
in New Hampshire who are eligible for
school breakfast that don't participate
so we still have a lot of work to do in
promoting School meals
further questions
thank you very much I'd like to invite
Nancy Vaughn American Heart Association
thank you
good morning chairman Ladd members of
the education committee
um for the record I am Nancy Vaughn
government relations director for the
American Heart Association in New
Hampshire
um and I just want to start off by
saying that this committee asks not only
great questions but the right questions
so hopefully we'll get all of them
answered if not today as we move forward
um I'm very happy to be here today to
testify and support of this bill House
Bill 572 the American Heart Association
nationally has prioritized our support
of
um of ensuring that every child in new
in the country as well as New Hampshire
has access to healthy School meals so we
do support healthy School meals for all
students but this bill does get us
closer to closing the gaps that we are
seeing and has as people before me have
have mentioned of people who are not
currently free and reduced eligible
um families but are still not able to
afford either a school meal or bringing
lunch in from home
and so I want to get right to some of
the questions that were asked that is
actually within my written testimony so
um representative Belcher had asked a
question a few times on the nutrition
standards and this is the data point
that is in my written testimony since
um 2012 when the USDA created the latest
updates to the guidelines for School
meals
um school lunches have become 41
healthier and school breakfasts have
become 44 healthier
during the pan well actually before the
pandemic back in I think it was 2017 at
the federal level Congress began
um allowing a little more leeway on the
guidelines
um there were meant to be additional
improvements to the 2012 guidelines
particularly in sodium so to a certain
point schools have gotten to the point
where they have reached the second level
of sodium reduction and there are two
more levels and unfortunately I didn't
bring the bill from last year with me or
my testimony but I can share that out to
you afterwards so last year House Bill
1561 I believe was the number was meant
to address the nutrition standards that
we were asking the New Hampshire
Department of Education to start with
those minimum standards at the federal
level and pick up where we have left off
nationally with the Sodium reductions
um the the federal program did not set
goals for sugar content and there is
science around how much sugar a child
should be consuming and to make sure
that that is represented in school meals
also the whole grain issue I believe
schools have met the um the the federal
guideline on whole grains but I believe
that there's another step that we can do
that we were looking for last year I am
not sure about the testimony provided on
that particular school district and why
that person felt that the meals were not
as nutritionally adequate but it could
be because during the pandemic there was
also food supply issues and there was a
waiver allowed for school districts in
every state to step outside of those
USDA guidelines for a period of time and
we actually am part of our bill from
last year had asked that the Department
of Education in New Hampshire look at
limiting those waivers and that before a
set amount of time and that the
Department of Education staff on School
meals could provide technical assistance
as to how schools could get back in line
with those guidelines but again because
of the pandemic that that was a little
challenging there were some healthy
foods that schools were not able to get
because it just wasn't available from
The Producers
so that was one point I wanted to make
sure I got across
and just in general you know we're here
because we want we're concerned about
the health of students we want all
students to grow up to be of a healthy
weight because if they grow up at a
healthy weight they're more likely as
adults to remain at that healthy weight
and children who eat better do well
academically more so than their of their
peers that are are not eating as
nutritious nutritious of a diet and
those who who learn who are better
academic results or outcomes get better
jobs and they can continue with Better
Health outcomes as adults
children who are who do better in school
and can get better jobs these people are
less likely to use tobacco products as
an example as a country we have not done
as well as adults even with our healthy
eating and physical activity so this is
something that we're still very focused
on and I so I think those are my key
points again my written testimony please
take the time to look at if you would I
also agree there need to be some
amendments perhaps to this this bill to
clarify some things which the sponsor
had mentioned and also the funding piece
I highly recommend that this be funded
through the state budget so again that's
my testimony I would love to get more
information to you on this after this
hearing and I'm I can take questions and
hopefully I can answer them if not I
will get the answers are there any
questions
represent belch we have about two
minutes left in this when we still have
two people to speak
thank you Mr chair I'll be brief uh
thank you for your testimony
um glad to see you're here actually Todd
ACLS and BLS for the American Heart
Association for quite a while
um I was just wondering if you do you
know I'll stop your head with the
guidelines for usdar for percentage of
um first for school students percentage
of uh calories that must come from uh
carbohydrates
um that I am not too sure of
um I know you know the whole grains gets
to that that point a little bit
um I can get I'll look that up and get
that answer too if someone else by me
doesn't have it if I may real quick I
believe it was if I'm not mistaken 50 I
don't want to it's not 100 but I think
it was 50 according to what I read
is that a proper amount of carbohydrates
for a young person to be receiving who's
living perhaps a not particularly sporty
lifestyle well again the guidelines that
have been set for for youth for children
we take that into account so it would be
you know for for for healthy Americans
is what the dietary guidelines are and
it could be that for someone who has you
know whether they have overweight issues
um would need to work with a a health
care professional to you know make that
a little different for them so the
guidelines aren't really meant to apply
to every single person it's just kind of
an average over that but um I will look
that up and get you more information
yeah thank you very much further
questions
not seeing thank you I'm going to jump
right now to the Department of Education
and uh we've had several questions
referencing nutrition and nutritional
value of the food served in the program
and
Kelly if you can please try to address
some of that
good morning
um Kelly Rambo Department of Education
um sure where shall I start um I just
handed
um representative Belcher a breakdown of
the nutrition requirements I am happy to
get a copy of that to you and you can
hand that out as well
the top portion of that you might not
understand
it's very heavy USDA and there's a lot
that goes back into that the bottom
section does break down the new um the
calories the sodium and they are
specific to each meal pattern and each
grade that the USDA comes out so there
isn't specific on to your question
previously on carbohydrates or along
those lines calorie specific to that the
calories are based on the meal as a
whole
do you have copies of that I only had
one um okay that should come around to
the clerk
um and um I can get you an electronic
copy so that you can um pass that up
are there further questions
representative cordelli uh thank you
um
maybe I missed it but looking at this
bill really it does not change anything
in in regard to nutritional standards it
has to do only with
um the household income level for people
to receive meals am I correct that's
correct as the bill is written yes
okay are there further represent
woodcock
thank you chair live
um thank you once again for your work
this summer as well as guiding us uh are
you able to answer a question that deals
with uh nutrition and brain development
and uh low-income Deoxys
um I can try but that
um would probably be somebody um for the
American Heart Association perhaps
that's not correlated with the 300
percent that we're talking about here
on topic here that we can have we can
get that information represented with I
don't mean to cut you off but that's
okay I'll get back to you thank you
thank you
further questions yes represent Balboni
well thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question could you just
remind me of what the federal
reimbursement level is right now per
school lunch
sure do you want um so the free is 130
and the reduces 138 all right but that's
percentage-wise what's the actual dollar
amount
um I can get you the dollar amounts that
broken down
um I can get you a copy of that okay
thank you you're welcome
further questions
not seeing thank you very much
represent Damon
good morning everyone thank you Mr chair
and thank you to the committee
representative hope Damon Sullivan
County District eight nine towns you've
heard me list
I've put my dietitian hat back on
the number one principle in nutrition is
you provide enough energy AKA calories
enough food before you pay attention to
any other aspect of nutrition
it is a fundamental principle that we
have to feed people something
before we address
what you have a diagnosis that needs a
particular kind of meal plan to treat it
or other needs people have to be fed
first
it's been noted that hunger creates
cognitive issues I also want to note it
creates behavioral issues
people of any age who have low blood
sugar have less emotion regulation get
irritable and impulsive much more
quickly this is very very well
documented not only in the community of
people who have diabetes but also in
just ordinary folks like let's say we
all skipped breakfast and lunch and I
suspect our tolerance of differing
points of view late afternoon would
diminish
it's just what happens if you're hungry
so that's my first point it's a
fundamental principle first to be fed
I don't think the USDA School Lunch
standards are perfect I will say that as
a a preface however
what people observe just from looking at
and eating the foods that are served
isn't the complete picture because many
of the items that are served in school
lunch are particularly manufactured for
the school lunch program
so for example chicken nuggets that
someone might buy in the freezer case at
the grocery store or at a fast food
franchise
are not anything that most people who
are invested in good nutrition would
promote
chicken nuggets in the school lunch
program are more protein whole grain
unsaturated fat they're made to
particular standards that make them
be a better quality product than what
you would stereotype them to be
do I think they're perfect no but
they're not we're underestimating them
is what I'm suggesting
and there is a balance that school lunch
people need to achieve between serving
healthy quality food and serving food
that children
find familiar and willing to eat and
that's true no matter who you're feeding
so I think that that is a tightrope it
is hard if you're coming from a
household where you don't have exposure
to truly healthy wonderful food
there is a learning curve to get used to
eating in a say fruit and vegetable lean
protein-centered way
one other piece I'd like to note I don't
want to go on too long the cost of
School meals is a bargain
I would challenge anybody to provide the
nutrient value of those meals for the
same amount of money at home routinely
it's amazing what they pull off
thank you for your time
thank you are there questions for the
representative
not seeing any thank you very much and
we're going to close this hearing
the next year in which we're going to
move into is HB 625 relative to the
calculation of average daily membership
in attendance and average daily
membership in residence for school
districts
foreign
cordelli uh thank you Mr chairman
honorable colleagues for the record uh
representative Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro Wolfeboro and
Ossipee in the beautiful Lakes Region uh
HB 625 does just two things
first it modifies uh RSA 198 38 uh
to indicate it is not just homeschool
students who have access to academic
courses in their resident Public School
District
um current law in 93 1C
indicates and I'll quote it from you if
you don't have your books handy
non-public public chartered or
home-educated pupils shall have access
to curricular programs offered by the
school district in which the pupil
resides
non-public and Charter Schools also have
access to curricular and academic
courses
as you'll see in the the bill in the
bolded text we have indicated that
um
it's crosses out home educated
and indicates that anyone who is
eligible to have access According to
193.1c which I I just read
um nothing has changed in regard to
school funding here it's bringing our
statutes into align with each other
um basically clean up
the second thing it does is a in
relation to uh high school programs and
courses and possible funding
in section two of the bill
um
online 13 at 12 and 13 you will see that
it removes High School
and indicates that
any academic course in grades 1 through
would be available to these students and
available reimbursement from uh the
state based on the current uh 0.15 per
pupil class
so those are the two things it does it
uh aligns our statutes in the first
portion and expands access to academic
courses Beyond High School to Elementary
Middle School also
and with that I thank you very much
representative Myler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so if this is just
clean up language
uh how does it change what what would
happen as a result of cleaning up this
language
um
thank you for the question
um I I think that what changes is in the
second portion with expanding it Beyond
just High School
um availability to
um grades one through twelve so that's
that's where the major change is
um in the program
follow-up please yes I I still don't
understand the cleanup if you clean up
this language what makes more available
who makes more who can have access
greater how do you see this changing or
who who currently under the current
language doesn't have access maybe
that's a better question thank you
um in 193
it states that
non-public public chartered and
homeschool students whereas here
currently in 198 it's limited to home
education compliance
foreign
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative cordelli for taking my
question if I'm reading this correctly
would this result in more funding going
to the public schools
um if more students from
non-public public chartered or
homeschool students are taking advantage
of courses available at their local
school it would because the school would
get reimbursed for those additional
students
thank you
representative Tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question if a child is uh
in an EFA program
and
um they're taking
a variety of different
um
ways to gain credit or they're in a
learn everywhere program a EOL program
does that mean that this suddenly makes
them eligible where they weren't before
to take curricular activities and also
um as a follow-up on that uh the
co-curricular activities can schools
still charge for them
uh thank you
um under
um the education Freedom account
statutes
um they are eligible to take uh courses
um at their local school but they would
uh pay for that out of their EFA account
um the state would not be a
reimbursement they would pay for that
out of their account
um and the second part of your question
yes uh the co-curricular so uh if a
homeschool student or
um Charter I I don't know the different
one EF EFA students do co-curriculars
uh such as you know sports or theater or
whatever is the school allowed they
don't get reimbursed for that uh because
it's only for academics uh courses do do
can the schools still charge for people
coming in and participating on those
um I I don't recall off the top of my
head
um what the provisions are in the EFA
um statutes for that
about that homeschooler homeschooler and
uh
the other ones mentioned in this bill
I'm sorry it is um curricular and
co-curricular
that they get did they I'm still
confused so yes and the state will
reimburse
a school
um Point what is it
0.15.15 for academic courses
do they also reimburse the school
for co-curricular activities that these
students participate in
um and thank you for the question in
lines 11 and 12
um it indicates curricular and cochlear
co-curricular is what I'm trying to say
doesn't say that it says that they can
reimburse for academic courses but not
it doesn't mention co-curricular
in line five right
um
0.15 pupil for each
um academic course taken in public
schools but it doesn't mention
co-curricular right
um elsewhere in statute
um it defines co-curricular as
activities which are designed to
supplement enrich academic programs so I
would think that um they would be
that's my reading um the Department of
Education behind me might have a
different different interpretation
I have a question for you
um when we wrote uh this legislation
here there was a concern that we had
coming in from uh the
nhia and school districts in regard to
co-curricular activity
and that they want to be assured and I
want to be assured does this still
enable a school district regardless of
where you're coming from being a
homeschooler EFA student another public
school private school etc etc
you must comply with the same policy
statements that are there for students
in that school offering the
co-curricular such as Athletics you will
have passing academics grades you will
not be smoking something or drinking
something that's not allowed and that is
very typical of those rules and
regulations are we changing any of that
uh no we're not those who would still
apply thank you
represent whitcock
good morning
um
the the uh definition or uh further
explanation of non-public school
students
uh you're talking about non-public
school Charter High School King can you
explain that for me so clear
um in statute and rules
um it frequently talks about non-public
the department approves non-public
schools
um the State Board I should say
um I understand that but can you define
what who they are who are non-public
schools that that would be applicable to
this uh inclusion into a curriculum
non-curricular schools uh basically uh
private schools academies so
thank you uh so
um a parochial school student a student
on eafa going to approach the school
Under non-public school would be able to
allowed to come to a uh public school
and take a co-curricular activity uh yes
I would think so I think if we were to
say they couldn't come from a parochial
school you would be in court the next
day based on recent uh Supreme Court
decisions
further questions represent parentnell
am I understanding this sorry thank you
Mr chair am I understanding this
correctly that currently there may be
students then who are eligible to
participate in curricular or
co-curricular courses for which the
school district might not be receiving
funding
uh the department can go into that but
um the funding is based on available
funding
so it is currently possible that they
might not get reimbursed but it's all
based on available funding um for the
reimbursement
further questions just so by cleaning up
this language
then we might be able to ensure that the
schools will receive funding for these
students
um
I would hope so uh uh the department
um I'm sure we'll be glad to answer that
question also I think just a little
clarification here we through our
funding formula for Education every
school district receives base adequacy
and the areas that differentiated Aid
it's incumbent upon the individual
districts to raise their money for
co-curricular activities
that's not part of adequacy
so locals have to do that that's why
many districts have activity fees to
participate whether it be intramural or
you know a competitive activity
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
just to clarify it says let's see right
here a student who is enrolled and a
school board approved Public School
academic
apologies do I need to reread that
all right let me start here we're on the
line four regarding student who was
enrolled in a school board approved
Public School course taken in a public
school
I'm sorry I skipped the line anyway this
shall count as a 0.15 student so if I'm
reading that correctly a student from a
private school would have to be enrolled
in at least one Public School course and
that public school is slated to receive
funding for this student if they're to
participate in these programs is that
correct
remember if you look at that statute it
says if the operating budget by the
state has the money for the 0.15 there's
no guarantee correct yes I just wanted
to clarify that part yes yes thank you
representative Woodcock if thank you and
the channel That in this I won't ask
this one uh on this bill remember the
Cardiology uh you responded to
representative Miler about cleaning up
and I'm looking at the what seems to be
a pretty simple change taking High out
of the word public high school
um is this not really a cleaning up this
is an expansion of raise one through
eight students which is a larger body of
impact than just cleaning up the word
taking High School which was you know
obviously nine to twelve would you agree
with that uh yes
um the cleanup was
um in relation to part of section one
but you're writing also in section one
as in section two it changes it from
public high school to public school it's
a huge expansion okay thank you thank
you representative and I'm just going to
follow up with a question that Keith off
of what you just mentioned represent
Woodcock and this was discussed when we
put the 1.15 uh possible reimbursement
for High School courses
and in the high school there are
designated courses one takes in the
grade schools there are
yeah they're subjects which we teach but
they're they're embedded in many
different topics
so the question is how do we Define what
the 0.15 is for the grade schools or the
elementary schools and Elementary School
technically can go right up through the
middle school
next question for me
oh how how are you going to Define what
the 0.1 I I I would think that um that
would be done through rules from the
Department I I don't have uh uh a
specific answer to you for that
thank you representative Lucas
thank you thank you for taking my
question I want to make sure that my
understanding is correct
my understanding is that we're talking
about residents of the district
and that because they are residents of
the district and have paid their taxes
towards their local school that is why
the students are eligible for the
co-curriculars
which are paid for by the local taxes
and that was I mean my son did that when
he homeschooled and and that was my
understanding I just want to make sure
I've got that right uh Yes actually
um I think it was two years ago there
was a uh
um a court case
um because
um a school in Rochester was done
denying access to a homeschool student
for a co-curricular activities
questions
representative Cornell
thank you
um thank you for taking my question
representative lakis was asking about
homeschool but does this include
students who are going to a private
school
um and then able to go to the public
school and try out for the basketball
team it's maybe even their private
school actually has their own basketball
team
um it does say non-non public in there
um
uh and co-curricular um I guess would
include the athletic activities
um so that's you know something you
might want to take a look at as the
Committee Member
good question
represent Damon
thank you Mr chair I'm not sure if this
question is for representative Cordelia
or for you will we have a fiscal note on
this before we proceed in executive
session because as a reference to what
working at the Department of Education
they're here for technical advice if
needed and we may need that technical
advice in the past the financial note we
we are tasked for looking at the policy
side of things
and the financial note sometimes doesn't
arrive until this is sitting in the
lapse of the fiscal division two uh
folks so we would be looking at if we
don't have one we'd have to act upon the
finance port or the policy side of this
thank you I'm just reflecting on
representative woodcock's question and I
think yours
about the K to eight change that does
not appear to me to be only clean up and
it seems like that would have
considerable fiscal impact depending on
how the 0.15 was ruled yeah thank you
thank you uh any further questions thank
you very much and is there anybody from
the Department Caitlyn that's going to
be prepared to respond to
some of the issues which we've just
brought up
that's Caitlyn's card right there
and we need to have Glenn did you get a
pink you got your pink card I'm going
thank you
good morning for the record I'm Caitlin
Diaz from the Department of Education
and I have my co-worker here Brian Eaton
who is relatively new to the department
and has some data for us
um I'd like to give you a base
understanding of how this current
currently works I believe
um this provision was put in law around
2016 and it was originally a proposal
that had come from
um senators in the Keene area as there
were many kids that were accessing
curricular activities or coursework at
the Keene schools that were homeschooled
kids and Keen had said would we would
like some adequacy funding for those
children
at that time the law that passed
then allowed
um
kids who were taking courses at the high
school that were homeschooled to be
eligible for a reimbursement for 0.15 of
the adequacy amount
for each academic course that the child
is participating in provided that there
is State appropriation and adequacy
formula so sometimes when the Department
of Education doesn't estimate as part of
a part of our state biennium budget we
have excess funding because when we're
doing the state biennium budget we're
several years out when we're typically
estimating that and so time sometimes
there's excess appropriation sometimes
there's not sometimes we need to ask for
a warrant for additional funding to be
available for us to pay that amount
since the amount has been or since this
law changed I believe we've paid it
around three times with the process is
that is is for us is when the school
district
enters their end of their day data they
tell us how many home school kids at the
high school level participated in an
academic course we have a definition of
academic course it's defined by a
national student course of course I
forget the name of it off the top of my
head
um the it's called the sched code and
it's a school course in exchange for
data it's a National Database that we
use to kind of Define courses in general
and schools submit that data to us we do
then do a calculation and at the end of
the year if we have excess adequacy
appropriation in our budget we will pay
that to the school
so right now
um this the law is specific to home
school children it does not talk about
all children that are eligible for
curricular and co-curricular activities
so as representative Cardell you
mentioned so this now refers to a
different section in the law for all
kids that would be eligible which would
include non-public Charter and
homeschool eligible children
um to your question representative
Woodcock when we're talking about a
non-public school so
we all talk about the word and use the
word private schools in New Hampshire
but there is no legal definition of
private schools when we're talking about
K-12 education we're talk non-public
school is the term that we use for all
schools that are not considered a public
school
that are approved by the Department of
Education
um so that's our current process that we
do right now so this bill expands the
definition to include kids that are so
we right now homeschool kids only and a
per class basis this does include
um non-public and charter school kids
that would be taking courses and then it
does expand it not only through high
school but to include grades one through
twelve now we do know there are kids and
school districts call us fairly
frequently and say especially throughout
the cut the pandemic as kind of
education and learning change for a
variety of different ways through the
last couple years saying we have a lot
more homeschool kids that are taking
coursework at the elementary school
level are we eligible for that Aid at
the elementary school level and we say
no the law right now is specif is
specific to high school only so that's
the way we currently work Brian has a
few numbers he's just going to tell us
essentially how many kids have submitted
and how much the cost would be based on
our very narrow data set that we have
right now so before we go to Brian can
we ask you a question here of course
um my question is that
now
I'm I'm having difficulty with
putting this 0.15 down into the grade
school level and I'm trying to Define
that we haven't they're very much
defined when we have the definition of
high school there which states that the
the level of grades following the middle
school or junior high school so that
would be a high school
so how are you as a department going to
decide that what they're doing at the
coming in for the language arts program
maybe at grade three is the equivalent
to 0.15 so the national
the national course registry does
actually say third grade reading or
third grade math or third grade science
so it does break it down to that level
of special specificity on that
coursework and we would continue to use
those same levels of definitions
so the question I want to follow that up
with is that that's what those national
standards may say
but in practicality what's happening in
our grade schools is that language arts
may be taught all morning long in
various courses or we may have it
embedded in the social studies program
as well so is someone going to come in
and want to only pay a 0.15 for being
enrolled in
the grade school for half a day
so right now it's 0.15 for a class so if
they were if the school were to say that
one class was taking a half of a day it
would still only be 0.15 they wouldn't
get 0.5 or anything like that even if it
were a full if it were a full day Arts
course for example it's still limited to
0.115
this is getting the same discussion we
had once before when we did this with
co-curricular and all that right we
talked about defining the 0.15 which we
did
thank you we'll go on with the rest yes
go ahead representative thank you Mr
chair for taking my question
um I myself don't like questions that
are hypotheticals but I'm going to give
you one
right now
these co-curriculars
and academic courses uh there's a space
availability issue like they will only
let the non-public school students do
these if they're space available is that
correct so right now
um this law is not changing who has
access to curricular and co-curricular
activities I am not sure how that is
implemented at the local level okay so
that was kind of just background my main
question is here's the hypothetical if
you had
say there was only room for one more kid
and you had a homeschooled student
and a let's say a Catholic School
student given the laws it stands now it
seems to me that the public school would
prefer to have the homeschool student
because they would get perhaps this this
funding
so uh how would you address that sort of
issue that we would rely on the local
school district to have a policy in
place to as a local District yes issue
but it's a law where changed then they
would be forced to use different
criteria they couldn't use the
I don't know if this issue is if I'm
expressing this clearly enough but I
understand you understand the issue I
understand okay and I just don't have an
answer for you okay I think the law
right now says it's up to the policy of
the local school district so they set
that policy and it may be different
between District X and District y over
here
further questions
further
right do you want to sure so
you know this bill is expanding to Great
school middle school basically one
grades one through twelve looked at
enrollment and it appears that an
estimate would be that the total amount
uh to expand to grades one through
twelve would be 137 000 for school year
22 enrollment and when we plug that into
the adequacy calculator which takes in
consideration the swept uh the actual
net increase would be 120 000 uh per
year
representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um the way this bill is written about
funds being available sounds to me
similar to the special ed
where uh now we know that schools are
getting reimbursed like at you know 40
50 percent of what they asked for
because the funds are not available they
haven't been budgeted
um
and I'm worried that with the expansion
of this uh and the expansion of of
um
you know that the public schools are
going to have a burden
of
being required uh to
allow these students to come in and take
their courses which
um then bumps up
their particular costs
um
and yet the state is not reimbursing
what we're
are what we're relying on is that the
Department of Education will make a
substantial uh amount available in their
budget to cover
let's say 80 to 90 percent of the costs
of local public schools
um through this program so
and so I want to clarify
um this bill does not expand who is
currently Acts or eligible to access
this coursework so the children that
this bill would pay for are already able
to access the coursework at schools
this bill only allows the Department of
Education to then include that number
and if we have appropriation to then pay
that so that's my first point my second
point is I know I'm getting a little bit
ahead of myself but the 1045 Bill does
actually remove that amount that says if
the appropriation is available and
specifies that the Department of
Education shall pay it no matter what
the appropriation is just like we do for
regular adequacy
yeah that's all about
your statement that this this bill does
not expand the number of students that
are eligible to take this and it seems
to me that's one of the points of the
bill sorry I did actually misspeak um so
as far as the homeschool kids it does
not expand but it wouldn't guess that is
correct it is it it expands it to the
non-public and the um charter school
children yes
well also actually the
I'm
I'm getting confused too so this is fun
um so those kids are currently eligible
to take coursework in the school per RSA
193 C or 193 1C or whatever it is
they're currently there they're
currently taking coursework all this is
doing is expanding the types of children
that are accessing coursework that the
Department of Education can reimburse
schools for but it's not reimbursing the
it's not expanding the allowable
categories for curricular and
co-curricular participation under that
section of the law
um so I'm confused now
um this is what happens we have a Friday
hearing yes yes and I probably didn't
have a good breakfast so
um
it seems to me that this is expanding uh
to the lower grades which
um I I have not had anybody tell me that
they're doing that right now uh what I
hear is that you know it's at the high
school level with like chemistry courses
and things like that and it's also
extending it to kids who are now
students who are now enrolled in uh
non-public
private schools that are not necessarily
home school students
so those kids are already eligible under
the existing law so
particip so we have two separate
category issues here so we have RSA 193
colon 1C and now you all have law books
now right so you should be very happy
about this so we can all follow along
together
um so and that law is access to public
school programs by non-public public
chartered and home education pupils so
this already talks about who is eligible
so these kids are already eligible to
participate at for at for curricular and
co-curricular coursework at their school
no grade level required so this is a the
existing law
the bill that we have today is now going
to allow the Department of Education to
reimburse schools for kids that are
accessing through this section of law
the current law allows the Department of
Education to only reimburse homeschool
kids and High School
so now this will be all kids that are
accessing it and then the 1045 Bill does
something similar and in addition allows
the Department of Education to pay that
no matter what our appropriation is
3C
um so go to page 506 in your book
s 506.
okay
it wasn't even close to that
and at the very bottom in the left hand
column that's where it starts
representative Lila
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
clarifying this for me did I hear right
that Mr Eaton said that it would expand
to 120
000 students would be expanded and
eligible for this that they currently
aren't available no that's the dollar
amount a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars oh okay excuse me thank you I
should specify that is the kids that the
schools are currently submitting there
are kids that are participating in
school in this coursework that the
schools are not submitting because
they're not eligible for these funds so
so question for you that is reflecting
what we have currently which is High
School
are you assuming then we're going to get
none from the grade schools no we we
absolutely would we just don't have an
additional data set to share on that we
and we have had schools that reached out
that said can we submit kids that are
not in high school for this and and the
school say why is it just high school
kids and then why is it just this so yes
this is we had that question at one
point in time and the question came up
how do you define what that time limit
is in the grade school
whereas we had a specific time for High
School courses based upon block
scheduling or the types of scheduling
that they are doing at their the course
starts and it stops so the teaching of
Concepts in the grade school don't start
and stop from 9 to 10 o'clock it also
carries over into where it might be
embedded in another science or social
studies class as well
so I'm I'm I'm you know I'm all good
with the high school that as we're doing
it and doing this for high school swirl
but I
I'm real concerned about the the and and
we do require
um for each course that is being
submitted or for each student that's
being submitted that the school specify
the course that is being taken so they
can't just say oh they were there for
0.7 of a time they say that Caitlin
Davis was here at this time and she took
read a third grade reading and then she
took second grade math or whatever and
well actually we and then so we say for
each one of those coursework and we'll
cap it at the traditional adequacy
amount we're not going to give more than
that so we're going to say for each
coursework that you're enrolling in that
is capped at 0.15
thank you represent Tanner
um just
do you have specific
um
figures for uh well this year may be
before covid and also maybe for this
year of
how many public schools submitted for
reimbursement
how much was actually reimbursed and
also my question is
um
when do they get that reimbursement so
does the I assume that The Homeschool
person student or non-public or whatever
doesn't even have to uh declare that
they're coming in for that particular
course uh so that the school district
doesn't have the chance to budget for
that
um and it if it's worked on ADM they
don't get reimbursed until the next year
for what happened the year before that
is correct it's actually paid at the
very end of the following year too
because we need to make sure that we
have enough appropriation to pay
everything else throughout the year so
in a summer a school will tell us how
many homeschool kids they had and and
the courses that they took and then we
take that ADM and we start doing our
October 1st calculation we pay October
1st November 1st January 1st and we come
down to April and we say all right well
our last we recalculate one more time
and we say all right we owed schools 700
million dollars and we had 701 million
dollars of appropriation so we can play
that homeschool amount or we only had
680 million dollars and so we can't pay
the homeschool appropriation so we have
not paid that appropriation at least in
the last three years
um and so we're talking about
hundred to two hundred thousand dollars
right now that we could have should have
paid based on the current law had we had
appropriation but we did not have not
had the access appropriation so you're
saying that in the last three years
knows public school got reimbursed for
extra students coming into classes is
that correct that is correct
further questions representative Myler
thank you what's the incident rate you
had for requests for this kind of a
payment in the uh Lo and the change
law
in other words currently it's clear
about the high school what's the
incident rate you've had for requests
from school districts 4K to eight let's
say so we don't have reliable data on
that because schools schools will only
the only reason that they're doing this
report is to get that adequacy and the
report does specify that it should be
high school kids so we don't have a good
great count thank you
further questions representative Belcher
coming down the line then from there
thank you Mr chairman
so it seems like a lot of the
questioning around this involves
reimbursement perhaps for students who
are participating in extracurriculars
and sports and whatnot so my question is
for those parents who are living in the
districts who are perhaps educating or
homeschooling or non-public schooling
their children and who are local
taxpayers in that District to these
schools assuming they're not getting
sped or any other special programs what
are they getting from the district for
those taxes they're paying in right now
that would be a great question for our
local school district
okay represent woodcock
thank you I'd like to go to back to
Brian because the because I get lost in
your two numbers
um if I may you started with 130 137
and then you went to 120 and and I got
the 120 being the money but I'm really
sort of confused if you just give me a
quick review of that
so
taking the adequacy base rate of
3866.18 and taking the ADM of those
homeschool students within school year
22 that total comes to
sorry one second
one thousand oh sorry 137 124 plugging
that ADM into our adequacy calculator
which takes in consideration to swept so
some you're right so
um that brings it down to 120 000 120
143.45
um
for those additional homeschool students
okay thank you thank you thank you
chairman represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so I just want to clarify my
understanding correctly then that we are
requiring presently
school systems to for 9 through 12
students
uh accommodate
or both curricular and co-curricular
with no guarantee of getting reimbursed
for it and if this bill were to pass we
would be doing that for all students
from any educational setting is that
correct
huh
yes I think so
thank you a little caveat though you
said the word require and in its
concordance with policy uh at the high
school level right now so there's going
to be other conditions for acceptance
into that course or that you know the
pro program do you have the
prerequisites to get into that course
and co-curriculars all kinds of them
I appreciate that yeah
and further questions of the department
not seeing you're off the hook
thank you very much and that does to see
close that bill
this is coming up
which one's this now
okay the next bill which we have we're
going to start in about five minutes
we're going to give everybody a stand up
here stretch it a little bit and we'll
come back and and start this at five
minutes of 11.
especially
some put that in a minute yeah I think
that I'm I'm good with it
um
course when it starts when it stops they
can Define the course but it's it's a
different ball game
I'll send the kid to the grade school
yeah for the record my name is
representative Deb Hobson and I'm
representative to Rockingham County
district 14 and I was asked to submit
this bill on behalf of the doe so you
can imagine my surprise when uh the
hearing before Isabel it's almost
exactly the same and it's an area that I
only know a very uh superficial layer so
I'm going to ask that Caitlin Davis come
up here and help me
from the DOE
can I do that
that's correct I have nothing sit down
okay perfect I'd be happy to relinquish
my chair oh and additionally I do have
an amendment uh for this bill so I would
ask that someone may be entertain me
okay great thank you
nope
good morning for the record Caitlin
Davis from the Department of Education
um let's start over let's forget the
last hearing
so I tried to give you all some kind of
information
um before uh but I think the first thing
that we want to think about is so we're
going to start from scratch forget the
last half hour that we've had here is in
your law book or computer or whatever
you have direct your attention to page
506 which talks about access to
curricular and not non-curricular
activities
so our co-curricular rather not
non-curricular
um so that
is the list of kids who currently have
access to curricular and co-curricular
activities at schools
So currently it says non-public
chartered and home educated students
have access to curricular and
co-curricular activities local school
districts have policies on who can
access them relative to your questions
about if students are you know our
classes are over subscribed and whatnot
but so that is that section of the law
we're not changing that neither of these
bills change is that section right now
then under RSA 198
that's the section of the law that both
of these bills are amending
that is the bill that the Department of
Education pays for certain coursework
so our current our current process is
the Department of Education pays for
coursework related to kids that are home
educated participating in academic
courses at the high school level
this bill which and I do have a um did
you pass out the amendment okay so they
have an amendment
um so the bill that you have in front of
you the one initially introduced on
behalf of the department
was the department had suggested
expanding it to 1 through 12 because of
the number of schools that had reached
out to the Department of Education and
was looking for additional support
relative to courses that they were
offering throughout the year
the Department of Education also had
suggested that we would get rid of the
language that we said to the extent that
Appropriations were available and said
let's fund this for every kid that's
taking a course so let's pay the public
schools for every kid that's taking a
course regardless of the appropriation
available to the Department of Education
so those were the suggestions that came
on behalf of the Department of Education
um the amendment that you have in front
of you
instead of
um just homeschool kids which that was
the original Bill the amendment then
includes
um all kids eligible to participate
under the existing law so all existing
kids that are currently eligible to
participate
non-public chartered and home educated
in in the
um so that does expand the number of
kids that we would pay for
but it does not expand the number of
kids that are currently accessing this
um so the only
kind of issue that I may be seeing now
of course with the amendment is that
it's a public elementary or High School
however we do have middle schools in the
state that may not fall under that
category of elementary school so we may
want to make a change to that as well
um to correct my testimony on the last
spell
um so we have paid this so This aid went
in place it passed in the 2016 and 17
biennium budget in the summer of 2015.
since that time we have paid this Aid
three times but I did say not in the
last three years which is incorrect we
paid it in fiscal year 17 fiscal year 18
and fiscal year 21.
to the tune of in 2017 134 thousand
dollars
um a hundred and four thousand dollars
in fiscal year 18 and 143 000 in 21. and
that is on
so the hundred and in 2017 of the
hundred and thirty four thousand dollars
we paid
that was included in the 927 million
dollars in adequacy that we paid
um a hundred and four thousand dollars
was included in the nine hundred and
twenty four million dollars of adequacy
that we paid and in fiscal year 21 the
143 to thousand dollars was car was
included in the 1.1 billion dollars in
adequacy that we paid
so
thank you yes so yeah
um so in 17 18 and 21
were schools reimbursed 100 of what they
um applied for yes
four grades nine through 12 home
educated students
okay and we're we're expanding that now
so
um the the budget should reflect
the budget proposal to the to finance
should
reflect the fact that we need a lot more
money in that particular area to cover
all the
um a lot more money depending on your
definition of a lot more money maybe a
hundred thousand dollars on a billion
dollars
[Music]
when the department went ahead with this
I'm still having a real gut ache with
the elementary schools
um
as an elementary teacher and an
elementary principal for all these years
I noticed and I I know that how we teach
the grade schools you can't say language
arts is only taught during nine to ten
for example today being the day in which
we remember the Holocaust and genocide
so we then look at the num the book
number of the Stars by Lois Lowry who
dealt with daring to get the Jews out of
Denmark to Sweden we teach that in
social studies but we're also having
kids read the Thematic reader as part of
our language arts program or we could do
another book Like Elephant In the Garden
by Michael morpurgo which deals with the
bombing of Dresden and trying to get an
elephant out of there and I won't go
into the story but it's all good reading
but it's done in conjunction with social
studies and literature so language so
when we're trying to gel this down to
you're going to get a 0.15 for a course
what is the definition of a course I
know you're given the national stuff but
that's not
New Hampshire is not National we are New
Hampshire and how we teach here is we
are trying to have thematic approaches
to this and I think it's the best way to
teach some of the uh needs that we have
in social studies through reading some
of this wonderful literature that's been
written for intermediate level students
grades three four five six so it has did
the department consider at all that of
course as we Define for the high school
is going to be appropriate for what
we're doing in the elementary schools
what our process would be would be for a
school to Define their course so a
school will have to select a course from
an existing list of coursework so they
will have to use their best judgment to
say this kid was taking a reading class
or this kid was taking a math class and
it is
aligned the specific course a school is
going to have to do that and before the
Department of Education will reimburse
them for that money
and I know this is not a question but
the department wants us to start getting
and taking this Knowledge and Skills and
applying this Knowledge and Skills in
the grade schools we apply it through
other courses well but it's all compiled
into learning how to read
so it doesn't start and stop between
nine and ten
as it would in Block scheduling or
scheduling at a high school which is
easier to Define because we're talking
about graduation credits we're not
talking about graduation credits we
talked about class and program when we
get the grade schools so
representative cordelli thank you Mr
chairman
um thank you Miss Davis
um
uh you mentioned about elementary and
middle schools
um and middle schools you know maybe
being covered
um and I was looking at
um lines 19 uh meaning of elementary
school is defined in 194 19a
right so this is very instructive
um based on another bill that we have to
re-codify our education statutes because
if you look at 194 19a the definition of
an elementary school it says for the
purpose of this chapter in elementary
school is set forth as in 189.25
so looking at 189.25 it says
um K through 12.
um
in elementary is any school approved by
the State Board of Education in which
the subjects taught are presented by the
state board for grades kindergarten
through eight of the public schools
so I think we're okay in terms of
covering Middle School levels but I
don't know if we want to change the
reference to the 18925 or
um but that's a great example of uh need
for recodification of our statutes
and further let me cut into that it's
further need to re-codify seeing that
middle schools Define its grades four
through eight right
and so we're talking about what we call
the intermediate grades when talking
about grades four or five and possibly
six
represent Myler
thank you Mr chair I'm going to ask the
same question again obviously this is a
this is a department request and so
there's got to be a basis for the
Department request from a standpoint I
would assume that you've had inquiries
from school districts
about expanding this through elementary
and middle school so I'm asking the
question again how often have you
received these kinds of requests
is there a need for this so we currently
collect
the data once a year from all schools
our current collection doesn't specify
that it's High School only
but right now so the grades levels that
we throw of this last year's date so
there were
1138 kids
that the school districts told us we're
taking coursework now these are kids not
courses so they each one of these could
break down to 1.15
of that
591 were in 9 through 12.
and 516 were in grades one through eight
and 31 kindergarteners
foreign
thank you
wood
if a child was getting their
language arts partially through history
and the child was there for
specific language arts instruction and
history instruction would that be two
courses
and could the fact that they're there
for half a day
and they're actually during that half a
day there for history there for math
there for you know could you
count 0.15 for each of those
and with that's
solve that problem and is that something
that could be done
I don't know the answer to that question
we would really have to have a
conversation with the schools and you
kind of say how does it break down to
the specific data prescriptive standards
that we've we've told them to report
that information on thank you
for the questions representative
balbooni
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um the previous Bill focused on grades
one uh through 12 and this particular
Bill starts at kindergarten through 12.
um what why is there a difference I'm
not sure the drafting difference
I am I'm I am not sure what the drafting
difference is I think thank you
representative uh cordelli and then
representative Tanner uh thank you Mr
chairman um thank you again
um so
um based on the 2022 numbers of 1138
kids taking courses that were
approximately uh 547 kindergarten
through eighth grade
um taking courses assuming each kid took
one course
um there are 547 courses offered by
public schools for which they were not
reimbursed but would be reimbursed if
this bill were to pass is that correct
that is correct
represent Tanner thank you
um
just the last statement you made about
the the number of students and and the
reimbursement
um in high school it's by course so it's
like chemistry course which may meet
every day or or whatever but in an
elementary school
um as representative laddis continually
talked about is different setup
could a parent
um
have a kid have their student have their
child go to public school on let's say
Monday Wednesday Friday and then
homeschool them on Tuesday Thursday
and uh get and would the school get
reimbursed 0.15 each day that the child
was in the elementary school
the entire year attendance isn't really
relative to it so if a child was to
enroll in a course we would accept
expect them to participate in the entire
length of the course I'm not sure
how your scenario would apply to this
but uh and and in elementary would they
get let's say if they went in from nine
to
to noon and there was language arts and
and Mathematics and social studies
taught during that time integrated
together would the school receive just
0.15 or would they receive 0.15 times
three it depends on how the school
reports to us they're going to have to
say that Linda Tana took a social
studies class or 0.15 and then a reading
class and then a math class the school
it has to be prescriptive as far as
saying the actual coursework that
they're taking thank you
uh I've got a question for you
um in the high school you oftentimes
will take the required courses maybe
some electives and maybe get a study
hall in there so you may be taking five
a day
um it's my understanding at least when I
was an administrator or principal over
in Maine that when we had the kids at
school for more than half of the
academic program they're accounted as a
as a student publicly enrolled in the
high school or the public school
therefore could not be homeschoolers
so we don't make that delineation the
Department of Education
um however we do have a Sasa number that
we're doing for each one of these so
there's no way of counting them double
if that's what your concern is
that's part of my concern I'm still
going back I hearken to kindergarten I
don't know how you're going to find a
course when you're just trying to get
the kids settled down for 10 15 minutes
this and then you're on to another topic
and then you're off the drawing and then
creoning and then
whatever it might be how you're going to
Define that did the department think of
this so I mean there's a kindergarten
cool there are kindergarten codes in
this
prescriptive course code work and that's
what we're going to rely on okay
all righty representative Myler thank
you thank you Mr chair and since we've
got the expert here
could you define and delineate the
difference between a d m a and a d m r
of course yes and something I can answer
so average daily membership and
residence is where the kid lives
adma average daily membership in
attendance is where the child is
attending
so you may have a kid who is
um part of the
see if I can pick a good example here
for admr purposes
um they are a resident of the town of
Epsom
but for adma they are attending Pembroke
Academy because they're high school kid
so they would be part of the ADM
so admr the B from Epsom adma they would
be from Pembroke
so so admr is where the kid lives and
where that's how we calculate adequacy
so the town of responsibility is based
on residency
adma is where the child is living and
that's how we calculate things like
enrollment and such
can you'd find a little bit more for me
for example I'll use my
Wilderness school kids going there but
they're a resident of the resident of
beholderness
holderness sends their high school kids
to Plymouth
so for ADM adma they'd be counted by
Plymouth correct and admr they'd be uh
on on resident of polarness correct okay
so I think we're on the same page
represent dry
thank you Mr chairman following up on
that in the Plainfield Town report it
lists 213 public school students for the
elementary school and then four
homeschoolers for a total of 217 and is
that because those are the ones that
might be eligible that's I always wonder
why there weren't private school
educated children included in that
number right we don't collect data on
where the private school kids come from
so the adma numbers and admr numbers
don't include any private school kids
um
if you're seeing a difference you may
have two kids
so if you may have an admr number that's
too high or is that what your example
said right when my children were there
it was my kid's number were the extra
ones added to the total
um they shouldn't have been if they were
homeschooled no
because we're talking about adma and
admr of public schools
just a follow-up
um and let me make sure I remember my
question
if this changes would they be included
in the total of students would
non-public school students also be
included in a total
um if this bill is enacted
and they were taking classes they would
be in an admr for the purpose of
calculating this essential the
differentiated as far as the adequate
education formula formulas involved but
not as far as other enrollment reports
okay thank you are there further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much Caitlin we really appreciate your
what you do you know you're supposed to
know everything about Finance which you
absolutely do and now you've been thrown
in the arena at the policy side too
um
we appreciate you
okay that concludes testimony on this
bill
and we're now into HB 501
sounds like we're buying jeans here 501.
um relative to ages for special
education services
thank you
yeah I know it this is your ADHD
I got to connect with you through that
too my bill
representative Murphy welcome
um good morning uh chairman Ladd Vice
chair cordellian honorable members of
the committee
um I'm Nancy Murphy here uh representing
Hillsborough 12 the town of Merrimack
um I'm here to introduce hb501 relative
to the ages for special education this
bill is a housekeeping bill in the
truest sense of the word
um its intent is just to make technical
corrections to sections of RSA that were
inadvertently overlooked and remain
unchanged when
hb1513 sponsored by representative wood
was passed last term
HB 1513 match the previous HB 1558 that
I sponsored in 2020 and passed this
committee 20-0 HB 1513 brought RSA 186c
special education into compliance under
current federal law it amended the
definition of a child with disability to
match both federal state uh federal
statute and federal regulations it
didn't raise the age limit of a student
entitled to a free and appropriate
public education it merely corrected the
ambiguity of RSA 186c in order to bring
New Hampshire statute into Conformity
with federal law there are eight places
in the RSA that were mistakenly
overlooked that need to be amended for
consistency with current law and HB 501
is meant to correct that
um they are found in the bill before you
I don't know if you want me to
review actually where they are but
they're in bold and they're
um they impact eight um different
sections of the law
you don't need to go through one of
those okay
um and I really that's that's uh it's
it's pretty simple and it's just
um unfortunately a couple of rounds it
took us to find all the places where
um the 21 inclusive needed to be
included and and um
eliminate any confusion with conflicting
statutes so thank you I think this is
exactly what we're talking about
re-codifying we don't have all those
hyperlinks that take us to where we need
to go when we make these changes it gets
under one and there's five others loose
right yep
representative Tanner I kind of remember
this bill from from last term yeah and
the fact that um you know we all were
concerned that uh a child with
disabilities would get to be would would
be in school start in September go
through
November and then say Oh you hit the
magic number and you're out um and I
thought we we um
we kind of worked around that so that
that didn't happen but it seems like
with this one it happens again
is that correct or not no it's not
changing anything
it's just there was just a couple of
inconsistencies where it did not get
changed to 21 inclusive so the laws
stayed the same it's not changing
anything that hasn't already been should
have been corrected when when you know
the statute was was amended
further questions
not seeing thank you very much uh thank
you
we have Karen Rosenberg
good morning I'm Karen Rosenberg policy
director of the disability rights Center
I think ditto to what representative
Murphy just said this is a housekeeping
Bill an inadvertent admission
um of you know noting all the places in
our special ed law that were impacted
when the legislature and Governor you
know signed into law this new law that
increases eligibility to 21 inclusive so
now that we actually have a definition
that's in Conformity with the federal
law in order to comply with federal law
fully we need to make sure that we are
providing a free appropriate public
education in our state law to all the
students who are eligible and so this
effectuates what you all intended to do
um clears up any ambiguity and um
hopefully it will get cleaned up and
we'll move forward so I can take any
questions but thank you are there any
questions
thank you thank you very much
uh Chris Bond
good morning good morning for the record
Chris Bond senior Assistant Attorney
General New Hampshire Department of
Justice
um we just well I agree with everything
that's been said so far we understand
this to be a housekeeping Bill to to
make changes consistent with the change
made last year we just wanted to
reiterate on the record our
understanding that federal law does
require the h21 inclusive standard so
I'm happy to take any questions but we
just wanted to make sure since this was
being opened up again that that we were
clear that that was our position on what
the Federal Law requires thank you very
much other questions representative
Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question following on up on
representative Tanner's query does
federal law make any statement about
individuals who as many would become 21
mid way through the Academic Year
thank you for that question uh no the
federal requirement only speaks to the
age 21 inclusive language there's
nothing in federal law that would
prevent offering Services beyond that if
you want to go through a school year I I
do recall last year some discussion
about having it end with a school year
and that's permissible under federal law
so long as that fiscal year where the
child has already reached age 21
inclusive what the federal law
requirement is is that at age up to age
21 inclusive they have to be offered the
services it would be up to the state to
decide whether they stop them at that
which is the outer deadline or whether
they decide to continue
and we we would be agnostic on that
point but to be a requirement with
federal law the services have to be uh
offered up to age 21 inclusive yes
can you speak to what is happening now
in New Hampshire
um so
my understanding and that question might
be better directed to the Department of
Education folks but my understanding is
that since the law was passed last year
um special ed services are provided up
through age 21 inclusive there may be
school districts that decide to offer
services beyond that because they
wouldn't be precluded from doing that
but but
um
so I don't know what the practice is I
don't have any knowledge about that that
is occurring and but they would they go
beyond they're not going to get
reimbursed for that that would be
correct as well because the law provides
for the reimbursement up through that
atrium represent Belcher thank you Mr
chair
being newer the language is a little
strange to me 21 inclusive is that just
a more complicated way of saying 22 yeah
that's a great question yeah so 21
inclusive means the entirety of the Year
where you are 21. so basically up until
your 22nd birthday yep
further questions representative
cordelli thank you um
welcome back to education
um uh I think you were here for quite a
bit of this last year
um and um as I recall
um 21 inclusive was used because it
mirrors federal law am I correct in that
that's correct yes 21 inclusive is the
language in the idea correct are there
further questions thank you very much
for taking the time to
thank you thank you
and from the Department of Education as
needed do we need to have Rebecca
Fredette come up anybody on the
committee have questions for her
I think you're off the hook
okay well you do you have a question
I think she's indicating she can answer
my last question oh I didn't hear that
come on up Rebecca thank you
again I'm Rebecca Fred Adam the state
director of special education and to
your question representative Damon it
varies from town to town there are some
school districts who will keep students
until the end of the school year and
then will pay out of their local funds
for any Services they provide from their
birth date to the end of the school year
but there are also schools that will
have the student leave on the last day
that they are 21. some of them do it on
their birthday but some of them do it
most of them do it the day before
thank you you're welcome are there
further questions
thank you very much
not seeing any further pink cards up
here we're going to close uh 501
and move on to the last bill before
lunch
and we got to keep that nutrition up all
those calories we need some donuts out
there
um
HP 439 relative to the duty to provide
an education and contracts with private
schools or 30 nine
foreign
welcome representative cardelli again
thank you representative Glenn cordelli
still representing Tuftonboro Wolfeboro
um and um
section one deals with co-curricular no
I'm sorry and that's the wrong Bill
section one does deal with age 21
inclusive however
um and tries to clean up
um that one section of Statute in the
same way the previous Bill does so um
there is a duplication between
um that section and this bill and the
previous bill
this bill goes on and does one other
thing
um and
um
before I realized that we will have our
new books going around or copies of the
two sections of Statute involved in this
and
um
439 in lines 8 and 9 repeals
189 1 a
Roman 4
which is going around and is underlined
that is repealed because it include it
is for two reasons it includes language
that has been changed in 193.3
and duplicates what's in 1933 so
um it's a minor re-codification attempt
but
the language that is in
18918 duty to provide education room and
four includes the ability to execute a
contract with any approved non-sectarian
private school
that
non-sectarian language was removed a
year ago and that is correctly reflected
in 1933 which uh
in this context applies to town
tuitioning
so
you could say that this is another
cleanup attempt
and they back to basically those are the
two pieces of this
HP 439 and be glad to take any questions
yes represent McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you for bringing this
forward I'm just a clarifying question
to be fully consistent with federal law
we would need to pass both this bill 439
and then the previous House Bill 501 is
that right
thank you merge them
they passed the previous Bill to clean
up
the others didn't
feel that statute that has our state
language okay okay thank you
further questions from the committee yes
representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um this bill actually repeals RSA 189
colon one dash a
uh for Roman numeral four
um isn't that essentially the Croydon
bill
um that we passed that allowed for
schools that didn't have
uh didn't provide public education
During certain grades and this was um
with Croydon it was up to fourth grade
and then after that that the school
board could then contract with
non-public schools I I know we took the
non-sectarian part out of it
um but it was so that the school board
actually still retained uh the ability
to oversee the education of the child
that they were Contracting to another
school so is this repeal repealing the
fact that they can still contract
um or or is it just repealing the
non-sectarian part of it uh thank you
um the ability to contract for provision
of those grade levels to another school
is in 193 3 Romans 6 and 7. so that is
not impacted by
um this other repeal in this bill
was that was that
um 189
uh colon one was that the Croydon bill
um
uh I I don't remember which which was
the Croydon Bill and which wasn't I
don't want to tell you the truth you
know all I can remember is Kua and
Montessori school and all that other we
were discussing with creden wanting to
tuition their kids out to those
locations
I can't remember which belt was
represent Tanner but but we thought the
result of this is that schools still
that don't have public education can
still Croydon can still contract with
Newport if if they want to
correct yeah they can um if I could
expand they can correct they can
um contract with any school
for which they come to an agreement on
the tuition to be paid
and the local board has responsibility
for approving that yes
okay
further questions of Representative
cordelli
not seeing any and I have no more cards
on this bill
so guess what we're closing this so you
got you got some more time for lunch
thank you
you know this next bill starts at uh 12
45.
we're dealing with the uh differentiated
aid for special education
I thought that when we did the corn bill
it wasn't that a Senate bill I don't
know Senate bill yeah I can't remember I
can't remember there's so many bills
coming our way yeah
I realize everybody's jumping up to
lunch here
thank you
I'll say
yes
may I give the scoring for the bills
this morning the five bills this morning
with the testimony online numbers were
okay
so for the first bill we heard 572 there
were 78 support zero opposed
for 625 there were three support 33
opposed
242 post
501 541 opposed 63734
and want to post
thank you
um
these are first bill presenter
said or do you need a minute
before we get started this afternoon I
would just like to make a note that
tomorrow January 28th
is the anniversary of the Challenger
explosion
and uh we have in our
hearing here a note of Krista and those
of us that knew her and worked with her
um on the it's a very special day for
those of us who who knew her and uh
when my son and I were down at the uh
launching of the Challenger uh it was
not the historic uh day that we thought
we would see but uh it happened so I
just wanted to make a thank you Mr chair
um
I don't think so I think I think uh
thank you for the offering moment of
silence but I do think that there's a
those of us that were there
celebrate that each day in our own way
thank you very much
okay I guess we're about set to get
started with our afternoon session and
the first bill is House Bill 540
relative to adequate educational grant
amounts for pupils receiving special
education services
and we welcome chairman Rick Ladd to
present the bill
thank you very much representative
cordelli and members of the education
committee I got my pink card right here
it's all filled out so I'll hand it off
when I come back up
I'm here today to introduce uh 540 as a
bill relative to the adequate education
grant amounts for pupils receiving
special education services
so uh
I come from a community which is very
you know a community which is not a
wealthy community at all and we're we're
looking at you know our base adequacy
and our differentiated Aid uh com amount
that we get paid as are many districts
throughout this state and I believe the
amount for special education Aid in the
area in the component differentiated aid
for special ed is a little over two
thousand dollars per student two
thousand seventy nine dollars roughly in
some odd sense
and we provide that I've given you a
packet here and unfortunately when they
ran it off upstairs they
ran both back in front and I asked him
only run the front so we could have cut
the paper in half and done it back to
back but we've got so let's I'll try to
challenge you to go through it with me
um on page one there was a report that I
had that was presented to me uh by our
research staff months ago months ago and
it's put together by the American
institutes for research and we as a
state have used air uh uh for looking at
our grants and and our how we fund
education and we had the study
commission which we've looked at that
and within this particular section of
this report it looks at how we fund
special education services in the
schools and I underlined the first page
seeing that even this report is older
but it still reflects that we have 13
IEP categories you can look at them on
the first page whereas the one on the
bottom page and you can see them and
what we're trying to do or what this
report was trying to do is try to
identify are there certain uh categories
which can be lumped together and
weighted at a certain cost value and are
there some other categories which
require more service time that are much
more complex do you wait at a different
level than the first category and then
you can also look at a number of other
categories if you want to do that there
are a number of states let's go to the
next page in this thing
and before I I on page two you can see
the reef this is just the report before
I get into what the other states do
which reflects the number of of students
in uh special education services in our
state and this report here is and we've
been handed it for 2022 there's 30 917
kids based upon these numbers here and
you can see the categories to the left
and explains them down below on the left
hand side of the page
and you can see also the total number of
students throughout the state which are
in these particular categories you can
see some categories have a lot of
students in them for example you're
looking down specific learning uh
disabilities and there's 10 000 plus
students there whereas you can look at
death and blindness
only 10. and that kind of reflective as
you go back over the years here the next
sheet I put a couple and there's 2021 on
page four it jumps to 2006 and I show
you some other reports which we've
gotten Beyond older than 2006 2004 and
the difference repeat between this
reporting and what you see reported now
is we got information
prior from 2006 going backwards that
identified the types of programs which
we had in the state whether it be
home-based program individual non-school
resource room program self-contained
program modified rigor education program
and we had the information down below
whether it was presidential or day we
had responsibility for placement who
placed them in whether it was a parent a
court the district
um that information used to be provided
to us we don't have that now and part of
what I'd like to see happen is we can
start attaining this information so then
on page nine
we can look at this data and see and I
have underlined here all data reported
and this is in the air report are for
certain years uh 99 through 2000 but I
haven't changed great section two shows
how the total expenditure to educate a
school age student with disability
varies depending on the type of
disability you go to the next page and
this starts to get into the weighted on
page 10.
and you can see that even though some of
the disabilities are
are not called the same as they are
today we're still educating students
which have similar handicapping or
disabilities
and you can see that the uh as you get
up along that Spectrum here visually
impaired which will be the fourth one
from the right how you can see that
compared to
um a
learning disability a student learning
disability on the far left hand side and
the cost between the upper bound cost
and the lower bound costs are
significantly different we Fund in our
differentiated Aid every category the
same
two thousand some odd dollars
yet we know it takes a different amount
of service to provide that student the
needs that that student has and it takes
a in some cases real specialized medical
understanding and how to work with these
students if they're deaf and blind it
takes a real skill that you're not going
to have from a classroom teacher of
course and to get that type of training
even when you're in a postgraduate
program is very costly and it's harder
to find
than it is for example even if you look
at if you go up where I was at the
University of Maine when I checked out
with my daughter not in too long ago how
many slots you have for speech
therapists up they had 25 slots
available in their program manually for
speech pathologists that is ridiculous
when we know that we have such a high
demand throughout our country
going on to the next sheet so then I
asked our researcher back in September
19th this is Jennifer 4 to do some
research for search and find out okay
multiple weights for special education
funding which states are doing this and
which aren't
most are doing a weighted formula of
some kind
and you can see that on the next sheet
over which would be page 12 they took
several States and and showed you how
they're doing it
um for example seven states has signed
additional funding weights based on
student disabilities and you can see for
example Arizona has 11 categories
George has 15.
uh uh Colorado too
we have one
uh next group down four states assign
additional funding weights based on the
number of hours of service provided for
the level of service provided so some
weight by the category some weight by
the the time it takes to provide that
service
then you go down where you see Iowa and
Texas two states assign additional
funding weights based on student
placement
other words if you're placed in
residential of course it's going to be a
lot more than it's if you're placing
within the traditional system
and Indiana and Kentucky two states
assign additional funding waste based on
disability severity or incidence level
Indiana and Kentucky one state assigns
additional funding weights based on
student cost Pennsylvania Pennsylvania
has since been in real trouble with
their funding formula they've had to
read bake the whole thing we learned
that through the commission study going
on to page 13 I'm going to try to fly
through here
you can see on the bottom of this page
how Georgia this one example that comes
from Georgia from the education
Commission of the states I looked at a
report from the education Commission in
the state's only 39 States at that time
were waiting out their formulas
and so you can see category one two
three four five categories and you can
read and see what types of uh needs are
placed under like category three or a
category 201
so we introduced last year a bill
as an amendment to SB 420 that's on page
14. and the attempt to try and get
weightedness into our education formula
was attempted and you can see on the
back page on page 15 it shows how we
added in here to the extraordinary needs
Grant by way of an amendment that there
was
the base cost of two thousand thirty
seven dollars eleven cents and then we
had category a and category B category a
you can see included certain uh online
23 going down through 29. you could see
the the categories which were added
underneath category a and category B of
service
but then looking at that and working
with folks and asking questions over at
doe and through spokes such as uh Becky
I don't know if Becky's here right now
or not
um Wilson that there are a lot of
overlapping needs which are bouncing
they're multiple handicapping conditions
and it was hard to and some of them even
though it may have been speech and maybe
the intensity of the speech in the IEP
which demanded more time than a student
that's just in there for his or her
pronunciation of the letter R probably
from Boston and so so I put aside that
now and I've gone to page 16 here
and looked at the individuals with
disabilities Education Act idea Part B
what kind of information is reported to
the the feds and they there is one way
of doing this and that's based upon the
time that the student is receiving
service during the course of the day we
saw that as a possible weighted uh
version that some other states are
currently doing
and we know that there are some students
which receive that service throughout
the course they especially some that are
orthopedically handicapped or immobile
we know oftentimes that those who are
visually impaired same slows with
traumatic brain injury require an
intense amount of time and so what this
bill does now
you go on to page 17.
this is how the LSR was presented that
was LSR 48 now it's hb4 540. the initial
LSR replicated what we had in the
previous Amendment last year
this shows you where things were struck
and it says now an additional twenty two
thousand seventy nine dollars plus for
each pupil and admr who is receiving
special education services with a
category a
they would receive the 2007 uh 79.89
category B would receive 4
729.78 these are for and it'll explain
down below for less for uh more than 80
percent of the time that they're
receiving that service the first
category for B would be for Less
uh then then uh the category a applies
to pupils receiving special education
services for less than 80 percent of the
school day category B with if you
receive a service more than eighty
percent of the day and category C
applies to students uh that would
receive special education services in
separate schools residential facilities
or homebound Hospital placements that
technology that wording comes directly
out of this data fact sheet as you can
see right at the top going back to page
16 uh under the idea it references in
separate schools residential placements
homebound slash Hospital placements so
we're talking about that child that we
once called cat Aid now special
education Aid so this does not suffice
for the cat Aid or special aid but it
increases the amount that's allocated
and in the differentiated Aid component
from the two thousand dollars in the
case of the student that is uh cat Aid
or special Aid qualifying they would get
six thousand two hundred thirty nine
dollars plus so the last sheet
going through this quickly is how does
this reflect on what we're or compared
to what we're doing now on page 18
for total projected special education
pupils is 30 309 students
we know that in category a it's
approximately 88.5 percent you'd see
that number of students
category b nine percent
2728 students and category C 2.5 percent
of the whole which would be 758 students
you can see how that costs out with a b
c down below with a total of 73 million
dollars
uh Plus
compared to the current Formula if we
fund it all 30 000 students plus by the
two thousand seventy nine dollars that
comes up to 63 million dollars plus the
difference is this would cost 10 million
dollars to put this in effect
roughly and so this is basically the
concept of this this is similar to that
it's been implemented in the state of
Washington
and let's see the next sheet
oh I just put this in here because
oftentimes we we discuss special
education we ask what is an
accommodation what is a modification in
the classroom simply put an
accommodation of just how a student
learns while a modification adjusts what
they learn so oftentimes the students in
the class how they learn it we can
modify that in the classroom while a
modification adjusts what they learn you
have to change and and you have to take
into account the handicap capping
condition to determine that one so that
closes my presentation on this bill I
think it just explains to you that we're
looking at a weighted formula for our
differentiate Aid getting away the
weighted formula concept was also
introduced by the commission for
um
studying our our funding formula this is
not the same waiting amount that waiting
amount was 4.19 I believe times the base
amount
um
this this recommendation here somewhat
based upon a what we have as possible
available dollars I'll be honest with
that however it's also trying to say
that there's certain categories which
I've doubled the number each time to try
to come at a factor or a number which
will definitely help us in in all our
districts this is something which will
be applicable to every District in the
state thank you
uh thank you uh questions for the
representative
great um yeah looks like you're going to
get off easy yeah oh I'm sorry I'm ready
to get out of here yeah representative
Cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um in the cap on the on the page where
we can look up how people vote oppose or
support the bill there was one letter
from from a parent whose son was um
multiply handicapped I guess and and but
they wanted him to be mainstreamed as
much as possible to to gain from the
class and whatever and I think the fear
was that instead of doing that if you
would get more money by keeping the
student in a resource room or less
mainstreaming to get the 80 there will
be less inclination to try to include
students into regular classes that's not
the purpose of this in other words
there's going to be a pair of with that
person in the classroom I'm sure okay so
that would come towards the 80 as far as
I'm concerned yes uh that that is that
is uh part of the IEP okay and it's
being carried forward into the classroom
okay thank you
uh representative McDonald thank you and
thank you it's a really important issue
so I was wondering on your written
testimony page 17 you have crossed off
changes that you had from a previous
idea one of which is listing a
non-exhaustive list of specific
diagnoses that may be included do you
see a value as to maybe adding that in
addition to
how the bill 540 is currently voting for
just be non-ambiguous or is there just
no added value to that if we were to go
with the categories that you know we had
in the amendment last year which are
those that you've like category a would
have included developmental delay
specific learning disabilities which is
fairly common
uh speech and language impairments
that category would receive the lesser
of the the amount category B would apply
to pupils receiving special services
includes autism deaf and deafblindness
emotional disturbance hearing
impairments multiple disabilities and
luxural disability and other health
impairments for Orthopedic impairments
traumatic brain injury acquired brain
injury and visual impairments you can
see that this category right here has
many of those categories which are going
to require more instructional time than
a student has a learning disability in
reading and gets that support from the
teacher for reading and then is uh and
probably can do that in the classroom as
well or in some cases it needs to
specialize in Mayco to a resource room
for 45 minutes whatever the IP might
save
um that category right there the two
categories like this there's some
blending though because oftentimes
there's there's multiple issues between
and and if you were to ask me to really
explain why those categories over here
versus these over here
um I really couldn't give you that
answer I have to rely upon people that
are like a Rebecca for that are those
that are involved with this but I can
tell you if we did this bill the way it
was presented we'd be talking close to
15 million dollars okay 14 to 15 million
dollars so it'd be an additional four or
five million dollars to do it by these
categories but then we'd have to really
square away and say has representative
Ladd gotten the categories correct are
there some other categories blonde
category a or from A to B I'm not that
expert my background is I've worked in
in schools we received awards for how we
had intervention in our schools and how
we ran our IEPs and providing the
support I had all the specialists in my
Elementary School everybody from a
psychologist to speech pathologist
physical therapists occupational
therapist I had it all and I was very
fortunate we had Arco up the road paying
the bill uh if we don't have that you
know here so
um I I would I would refer that back to
the specials when it's a good question
all right thank you question
representative Tanner
um the other question that kind of came
up on the uh online
um submission was the the percentages
and how they're determined and whether
having an extended summer program where
they would be 100 in it would
um put them in a different category and
again make it less uh a least
restrictive environment kind of thing I
went with the percentages simply because
it is a format already under idea right
so whether it's inclusive of your
extended IEP which would take you
through the summer because you don't
want to see a lot of loss uh during the
summer and I had that written in IEPs as
well and that it takes extensive money
we also had kids which were evaluated
through the hospitals up in Anchorage
for a neurological issues we had to flip
that bill too back then because we
weren't working closely with HHS and so
there there are a number of issues which
need to be addressed and that would be
one I would I'm not going to assume
anything I'm going to let you ask that
question too you know how you
incorporate those costs into this
percentage okay thank you
um for the questions
um see none maybe I'll ask one
um looking at the um weighted averages
in other states I've seen concerns about
um
the funding and the greater funding if
they're spending more time outside of
the regular classroom
do you see any problem down the road in
schools taking them out of the regular
classroom and into a special ed class in
order to receive the greater funding
there may be always some manipulation
within your how you you present a budget
but I hope that's not the case I hope
what we're looking at is that right now
we're looking at a truly an unfunded
mandate and we're looking at
we are required to provide the an
appropriate service to all these
students with an IEP
I question if we're able to do that with
two thousand dollars
uh per pupil it it just we can't even do
it with six thousand dollars per pupil
but we certainly can do it better with
six than two and so I I guess I knew
where I first learned about the weighted
formula was when I saw the research from
ECS years and years ago from Texas at
that point in time they had more
different categories than any other
state in the country
um so I would say that I'm doing this
simply because yeah there could always
be manipulation I hope not I hope
there's good oversight
but I I want to see that as being able
to provide that service for districts
that need the money to provide this
service
thank you for the questions
representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much representative Ladd for
putting this uh
um keeping this uh this initiative going
this was obviously something that I
think was very supportive from the
committee was very supportive of um uh
last year and um and I also appreciate
the um the the change with respect to um
hours of services as opposed to
um categories but um my um
my question actually goes the question
actually goes to the last category C uh
which is uh pupils receiving special
education services in separate schools
residential facilities or homebound
Hospital placements that's sort of a
category as opposed to a number of hours
and in a small District
um is the is is the Department of
Education going to be able to or for a
small District going to be able to
disclose uh that information which which
presently I think you know for if the
number of students is under 11
that gets redacted on a district basis I
think we we need to ask how they're
doing they are doing it for example when
you have a child that moves in
and is needing a residential placement
that happens often like I mentioned to
you the small town of Piermont where
they had two come in the same year each
one cost 250 000 plus they didn't have
the money and there is State money
available for that so that is provided
the year after the cost so that
information is made available by
Paramount to the Department of Education
we have this youngster based upon the
IEP we have here where we have to have a
residential placement now how that
occurs in the goings on there I think
that can be easily answered from the how
they keep confidentiality and all that
that's why we have the Assassin's unique
pupil identifier and all that right
right no thank you and a follow-up so so
um it's um it's it's not so much that
it's that the Disclosure by the by the
department through through the funding
formula item identifies the specific
name or even assassin ID number of a
student but in a small District
a lot of um as I've been told people can
sort of determine or you know or may
have an idea who um who that student is
and I was wondering what sort of
protections I I you know in all reality
pyrmont's a community of what 670 people
the school has 67 kids in the school
um
everybody knows all in that community
and it's typical New Hampshire
so um how you get around that I don't
know if you ever will because that's
just the culture of our state
no thank you thank you very much yeah
any further questions
see none thank you representative thank
you
um if anyone is interested uh Rebecca
Fredette from the Department is here
um and is available for Testimony if
anyone has any questions for her
sure
um Rebecca if if you could join us
we might have a question or two
thank you representative cordelli my
name is Rebecca Fredette I'm a state
director of special education I will
preface this with I can answer your
questions related to special education
but you will have to return refer to my
colleagues in the back regarding money
representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for coming up for my question
um I was concerned uh about the 80 how
the 80 percent
um 40 you know the different percentages
of of the child's involvement inclusion
in the regular school how that's
determined when you may have a student
uh who is included 80 during the regular
school year but then goes on to the
Extended Learning over the summer uh and
that's 100 percent and and would they
then
be disqualified for like
be put in a non-inclusive situation when
they were in the regular school year
thank you for your question
um so the esy services are extended
school year Services would not be
included within the determination for
least restrictive environment because
that's what these calculations are or
lre we just look at the so we have the
New Hampshire special education
information system and every District
puts in they either write their complete
IEP within that system or they put in
the data that we need to calculate our
indicators from the federal government
and so lre is one of them and it looks
at the services that they have and what
setting they are in so are they in a
regular education setting or special
education setting or are they in a
separate school and then it also looks
at and then determines the length of the
school day and come looks at those two
numbers to say okay they're over 80 or
they're under 80 or we've placed them in
a separate school so it looks directly
at their individual IEPs to make that
determination
oh
um do you have any fear that it's going
to create
um incentives or disincentives to move
uh special ed students around in these
percentages
um it would be a concern but um we also
have on the um other side of that
through our state performance plan
annual performance report or spp APR
that we provide to the federal
government each year we have a target
for where your lre should be for both um
K through 12 and for preschool so we if
they were to go above that Target we
would um it could trigger monitoring
with them and it would trigger us
working with them through our indicator
monitoring to say why is your number so
high what what are your criteria for
placing children in a more restrictive
environment you know are you doing these
practices because you want more money
for each student so we it it would be
followed up with our monitoring process
and we would be aware of that because of
this bill and be able to say all right
we need to go talk to this school or
that school because their numbers
haven't increased above our Target
you can't be able to yeah sorry would a
parent be able to
um question that as well the placement
yes they can yep thank you further
questions representative oh I'm sorry
represent McDonald thank you and thank
you representative for it as well I
might ask this question a moment ago and
I just want to defer to you thank you
for being here for taking the question
would there be any added benefit to
maybe
adding to the spill
diagnosis that might fit these
categories I know you can't possibly
include all of them within the language
of a bill but just to give more of a
guide to
school districts or to parents as to
what amount I guess what dollar amount
their child would receive
thank you for the question
representative McDonnell
um when the bill came up the last time
it was presented that was the um
consideration was to look at
disabilities and it's very difficult
because you have a wide spectrum for
example if you have a child with a
disability that's autism you could have
a very low low functioning autistic
child or you could have a very high
functioning autistic child and they're
going to have a variety of services
based on what their needs are so just so
to put autism in there for somebody
who's high functioning they're really
not going to have as many costs as
somebody who is more low functioning so
that was kind of the that it made it
difficult to try to say yes this is this
one would cost more that one would cost
more whereas this one I think is more
indicative of if you're not in the
classroom as much you you really do need
more services and if you're in a
separate School you really need a lot
more services so it's it's as you need
more services that price kind of
increases for what you need to be able
to pay for those supports all right that
makes sense thank you you're welcome
representative Fortin
absolutely
as a person who spent almost all of an
attack Academic Year is a para to one of
these students we're describing
I wonder if you could comment on what
kind of data there is on the I guess you
call it outcomes of providing that kind
of support from an academic development
of the student perspective
so it's going again not to defer back to
it's going to vary from student to
student it would be really on those
annual progress reports that are done
for each student has the support of that
paraprofessional provided them what they
needed to be able to be successful have
they met their goals that are in their
IEP
um or they provided the supports that
the team felt was necessary to ensure
that they were receiving free and
appropriate public education
so it goes back to that IEP and really
the progress the student makes so and
that would be predicated on somebody's
assessment of their status at the
beginning and yeah probably at the
conclusion yep and the data they should
be collecting each quarter and Reporting
on to parents or trimester depending on
the school and so they should be
collecting data around the students
progress and how they're doing and be
able to report that to the parents
thank you you're welcome any further
questions
we've seen none thank you very much
and
I don't think we have any other cards is
was there anyone else who wanted to
testify there was one from the
Department of Education
um without a name
um but uh
um
seeing no one raising their
raising their hand
um
we'll close this hearing and our next
hearing is in about 20 minutes
foreign
which we've received from the Turkish
Consulate in Boston regarding one of the
bills which we've recently heard you all
got that because we had copies here as
well you know
was it for everybody yeah well they they
made sure they got a hold of every one
of us then
it's yeah it's got a good seal on it
thank you
another tree
thank you Mr chairman uh fellow
committee members for the record Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro
Wolfeboro and Ossipee and uh
HB 530 is the result of the work of
several people several groups
trying to look at
a fairness in relation to the
withdrawal process and allowing
districts to withdraw from a Cooperative
School District
as we've heard over the past term in a
number of cases and we'll be hearing
more I think again this year about it
I think it's something like two times in
the past 60 years
a district has been able to withdraw
from a Cooperative School District
uh mainly because if a smaller School
District wants to uh wants to withdraw
from a Cooperative District
it requires the vote of the entire
Cooperative District
and in most cases
the smaller District would be out voted
by The Cooperative
in this bill tries to address that with
a more fair We Believe approach in terms
of the vote to withdraw
and um on the bottom of the first page
basically on
um 15 on down you'll see three scenarios
on line 15
very simply if the majority of Voters
voting in the pre-existing District want
to withdraw but vote against withdrawal
then the process has ended
secondly going down the line from that
if the voters and the district
vote in favor withdrawal
and the voters in The Cooperative
District agree and also vote for
withdrawal of the smaller District the
process continues
and now the third scenario which is a
new scenario
if three-fifths of the voters voting in
the district that wants to withdraw vote
for withdrawal
then they would be able to withdraw
unless
a three-fifths majority of the voters in
the entire Cooperative District vote
against withdrawal
so it's trying to balance out
um uh
and present a fairer approach to the uh
smaller District that might want to
withdraw from a Cooperative district and
their whole host of reasons why a
district might want to withdraw
there'll be other bills that we'll hear
this this year that will address some of
those instances
but we believe that this
will provide a greater opportunity for
those districts who want to withdraw to
have a chance to withdraw which they do
not currently
and I uh thank you and um I'm open to
questions
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so if I understand this right
uh on line 22
there are two procedures that take place
first would be the district within the
Cooperative District
would have to have a three-fifths vote
to indicate to the total Cooperative
District that they want to withdraw is
that correct that's the first step
then the second step would be
what if if the um three-fifths is a is
an affirmative vote
then there's a second vote of the total
District
that would have to have a three-fifths
vote is that correct
um
I was thinking it would be one vote
and
the cat the
um withdrawing District
if their votes would be counted and then
the entire vote uh for the Cooperative
district recounted for the fifth
three-fifths numbers
that that this this is confusing to me
because I think how I read this and I
may be wrong
I read that the district Desiring to
leave
would give notice through the
Three-Fifths vote of that District alone
to the total
to the total uh Cooperative District
that they want to leave and then the
totals there'll be two votes that's how
I view this I I mean maybe wrong that's
all yeah I'm trying to get clarification
right I think that if the Three-Fifths
of the
this drawing District vote for
withdrawal
that information would be sent to the
clerk of the Cooperative school district
and to the State Board of Education to
certify the warrant and posting of
minutes unless unless the Cooperative
District votes
in a three-fifths majority against the
withdrawal
I think unless is a key word there in
line 26.
further questions representative
woodcock
thank you chairman
um representatively uh think about the
fall of the same uh information that
President Milo was as I read the line
26. I'm also confused because I read it
as a second vote because line 27 talks
about the art in the end of 26 and the
27 it talks about the entire Cooperative
District vote whereas that where is 22
only talks about those that are there
for that particular vote it seems to me
that 22 is talking about those that come
for the withdrawal vote
and that that's affirmative because the
entire Cooperative District vote I mean
I just that's all that's my confusion so
yeah I I believe the current process you
know withdrawal vote irregardless of
this new language with the Three-Fifths
I believe that it's a one vote process
but does it
so thank you so the the three fifth year
you're so your position is that this
22-27 is still a singular vote Yes okay
thank you thank you representative Lucas
yeah the whole process is laid out in
the first part you can't take that
second part separately and so it lays
out how the plan is put in and okayed
and all of that and then they call this
election and it says what the election
should say
you know the school district accept
their Provisions as men provided the
withdrawal of the pre-existing position
of what from this Cooperative that gets
put towards it for everybody in the dist
in The Cooperative district and then
we're just looking at the results of
that vote is that if they're both
negative if the first one is negative
the if the little District that wants
out is negative we end there
if it's positive then we would go
forward unless
the whole vote is negative you know
three-fifths of the whole vote is
negative it's just laying out that what
are the results of the vote we've
tallied the vote and we look and see
what it is and these are the things that
happen based on the results of that vote
but the whole first section lays out
that vote
um
if you're asking me a question about
that then
um uh yes and I think lines 11 through
14 lay out the form of the vote which is
what you're trying to point out as well
thank you are there further questions
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um forgive that I did not have time to
research this but are there other rsas
or somewhere that it is spelled out
in a withdrawal plan from a Cooperative
District that they have to have looked
at
all the impacts financial and otherwise
in I would parallel it perhaps
to when a community leaves an SAU
it has to not be detrimental to
the any of the resulting entities is
there something like that in RSA yes
there's
um
extensive language in this chapter
related to the withdrawal process and
the dissolution of assets etc for any
withdrawal process this is just the
section on the vote itself
oh yes
so
in that extensive process has the state
board or doe approved the idea of a
community withdrawing from The
Cooperative before any vote is set up
as you see in line two if the State
Board approves the plan for withdrawal
I think where we're going to have to go
on this is that for those of us sat on
this committee last year
we went through extensive extensive
um discussion regarding how to get out
of a cooperative
School District it's like a divorce and
it's very difficult to even get that and
I'm sure we have some people here
they're going to be able to speak on
that they're coming from the Carroll
area which I'm familiar with what's
going on up there or what's what's
happened but there I think what we will
have to do is do what we're doing with
some of the other bills have a little
presentation on this whole process so
those that are new to the committee
which is half of you need to have an
understanding of what is the process
currently on the books for how you get
out of a Cooperative School District
because there's a whole lot of
information which you need to know you
know that that that the the all that so
uh with that um any other questions for
representative cordelli
if I could comment
um one thing this was not
developed with any particular
Cooperative District or any town in mind
I had a question from the Press about
that but this was developed as a generic
withdrawal vote solution
similar to many of the what we did last
year we tried to bring up a lot of
scenarios like this
hit a lot of dead end roads yes uh let
me ask question so you talked about I'm
I mean last going back to last year we
had talked about having a you know
committee and really diving into this
and and um in a different way and you
spoke about several groups that had
worked on this I was wondering if you
could tell us what some of those groups
were
uh there were some other Representatives
um and a collection of uh people from uh
up north not a group in particular but a
group of individuals
further questions of Representative
cordelli
thank you very much
like to have uh Chris Pappas please
um
okay there you go
and the appointed representative from
the board of Selectmen from the town of
Carroll on school reapportionment and
withdrawal matters
the town of Carroll joined SAU 36 around
1963.
we asked to get a new apportionment
formula in 1988 2004 and
2021-22 the Board of Ed
voted against putting it on the ballot
2022 we had to go to the State Board of
Ed to get our withdrawal article on the
ballot because the SAU said no
a member of the State Board of Ed said
we were stuck in the hotel California
you check in but you can't check out
the Board of Ed did put the warrant but
under the they showed the impact on each
Town's taxes if Carol were to withdraw
who votes to raise their taxes
canals Hotel California is created by a
Cooperative School District when
economic assumptions and demographics
have changed we have six percent of the
students and pay 26 percent of the
school's budget
in 2021 the SAU agreed to have a member
from each members of the board and
Selectmen to try to redo the
reapportionment formula Carol proposed
changing it five percent a year for four
years
from 60 percent per student 40 valuation
to 80 percent student and 20 percent
over four years denied this made Carol
seek to withdraw we didn't want to leave
the district things were going to get
worse with our new revaluation
the district is made up of Five Towns
Carol has the smallest number of
students and voters
at the time this was done 21 students
were 47 voters 572 Dalton 109 students
voters 742 Jefferson 114 students voters
817.
Lancaster students 398 voters 2269 and
Whitefield 261 students
1701 based on 21 enrollment each town
has a representative to the board except
for Lancaster and Wakefield have two
they do not want to come up with
anything that would lower Carol's cost
and raise others Cal pays more than 50
000 per student not County Education tax
the tuition for UNH it's 15 500 for
residents and 34.40. for non-residents
something is wrong when we pay more to
educate K through 12.
Lancaster pays 7
590 I believe Carol is one of the
highest in the state and Lancaster's one
of the lowest in the state
in 2020 Lancaster got over 3 million in
state funds Carol nothing the total for
the SAU 36 was over 6 million none of
which went to Carroll certainly within
the same SAU this is wrong
we have asked to leave three times over
35 years
in 1988 Carol paid 47.99 per student and
Lancaster was 1783. that was two and a
half times more now it is six and a half
times more
things are getting worse and will
continue to get worse unless something
is done
Carol has tried to negotiate but we have
been out voted by the boa and the voting
booth Cal has just reevaluated the worst
year possible and town-wide increased 64
percent
we do support the bill but believe it
does not go far enough Carol does
support it based on our last attempt to
withdraw the results in that vote we
would still be stuck in the hotel
California it was like uh 75 percent of
Carroll voters voted to withdraw in 75
76 percent district-wide voted that we
couldn't
um there's a great place the essay you
had asked us to come back to the table
about changing the formula but after
Carol lost its state appeal they voted
to end the meetings account should have
more control over its student population
where they attend
SAU 36 was created 60 years ago and much
has changed
thank you are there questions
so you have articles of agreement can
you go through one more time and tell me
how many reps on the Cooperative board
Carol has Dalton house Jefferson
Lancaster and Whitefield right field and
Lancaster have two the others to each
through each the other three towns have
one each okay one one and one
so those two towns they control the vote
they have the most students
and pay the least amount
and one other question in the Articles
of agreement how did they establish the
the the cot your share for uh for pupil
costs is that based on uh average daily
membership or on valuation of property
um it's 60 percent 60 percent of the
charge is they call it ADM students 40
is valuation
we do have a high evaluation because we
have 400 homes that are non-resident
not send anybody to the school
is there any effort upon your your your
school district to shrink it from let's
say 60 ADM to maybe 50 40 and put the
added burden on on the valuation side
which would increase your costs
uh they said the default number for that
is 50 50 which would increase our costs
and they didn't proceed with that we
were asking it to go from 60 40
to 80 20 over four years five percent
shift a year so it's not to impact all
at once and one last question for you if
they went to this 50 50 would your cost
per pupil jump up around eighty thousand
dollars
I never calculated that all I know is
between
um what we give the district and what we
give the state is 70 000 a student now
yeah
further questions from the committee
I'm seeing thank you very much thank you
America representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I um Erica Leon a state
representative from Derry the only
single towned Cooperative School
District in the state this actually
dates back to 1959 where we had gotten
down to only two school districts within
the town of Derry I believe we were at
14 at some point around the turn of the
last century when they built Hood school
they took those two districts and turned
into a Cooperative school district and
so we had been a one-town Cooperative
School District ever since that worked
very well for the town of Derry when
school building Aid was different for
Cooperative school districts so they
wanted to keep it and they wanted to
leave that unchanged the laws have
changed around that so that now there's
no benefit and there's only hassle for
dairy to stay in Cooperative School
District however we're in this strange
Hotel California where there's no way
for us to dissolve our school district
and go into a local school district
I am coming to you today asking I have
some language that may work but probably
is not the right language to also add
some way that would allow a single
municipality Cooperative School District
to hold a vote to dissolve the
cooperative and become a local school
district that would make our lives much
easier our current superintendent
is interested in looking further into
the process to see what happens and many
members of the school board and fiscal
advisory committee also would like to
find explore becoming a local school
district rather than adding the 93rd
Bill to your committee this year this
seems like a very small one town issue
that I would appreciate as you have the
work session and learn more about
Cooperative dissolution if this would
fit into this or any of your other bills
it would be helpful for the town of
Derry to actually have an option to turn
from Cooperative to local at some point
so I can hand this out and I'm ready for
any questions thank you representative
Tanner thank you thank you for taking my
question could you uh give us um some
idea of what are the hassles and what
are the benefits of being a Cooperative
School District a one-town Cooperative
School District
um thank you there's just thank you for
the question there's just a lot of
confusion around it people don't
understand it and if they're so busy
trying to figure out why we're
Cooperative
um they think that that's because
Pinkerton is part of our school district
but Pinkerton is actually its own SAU
and there's there's just a lot of
confusion about what it is people are
following the local school district laws
and trying to go in with those and
understand what's going on
but as a single Town's Cooperative
School District were ruled by The
Cooperative School District laws but
there's no apportionment because it's
all one town so it's just it just makes
it a lot harder to investigate and
figure out what actually is going on and
how to do things correctly
further questions
yes represent McDonald thank you for
being here and thank you Mr chair do you
know of anyone may be anecdotally and
Barry who would want to remain in the
Cooperative are there benefits as to
doing that as a Singleton thank you for
the question when the school building
Aid formula was different than there was
a significant benefit that's why I'd be
looking to do this as a warrant article
so it goes before the voters asking to
just change it here and the legislature
doesn't make sense even if it should
most likely be a clear choice for the
voters of dairy
um just giving us a process to be able
to vote our way out of it would be would
be a very nice option so thank you for
the question thank you
we know that
most of our Cooperative districts have
Cooperative agreements articles of
agreement we know several do not
are your members uh in your Cooperative
voted at large or are they uh
for example I too am in a once one town
Cooperative School District Haverhill
Cooperative is one town
so we all ours are at large members what
do you have in your Cooperative
um thank you for the question and the
information I didn't realize you were
also a single Town Cooperative we are
also all at large members we have seven
members on the rotating three-year basis
was at one point in time there another
District within your town which may have
cost that original Cooperative School
District as happened in April
um yes back around 1900 there were 14
different school districts within Derry
they Consolidated down to two around
1959 Hood had their dairy farm in Dairy
and they donated land to build the
Gilbert Hood middle school and the
elementary school that's on the same
location and as they did that it was
bringing all the students into one area
so it had to become one district and the
way they did that was as a cooperative
I think there are several districts that
did that further questions
yes represent Tanner
um thank you so you have a number of
elementary schools in in Derry
um and if you're if you create withdraw
from The Cooperative does that split the
elementary schools up into different
districts or
thank you for the question we wouldn't
want to split in back into the two
districts we'd simply want to go from
being the only interest in Dairy is to
go from being a Cooperative to a local
school district so that when people are
trying to figure out what to do they say
dairy's one town I'm looking at the
local school district laws they would
actually know where they're going I
don't think that it would change any of
the elementary schools and as far as
that goes there's already a discussion
in town about whether they would build a
single Elementary School that would
serve more of the students and close
some and as you'd be as you probably
would not be surprised there's a lot of
contention over that but that's a local
issue
further questions
thank you very much thank you and
another card which we have on this bill
530 is bear Christina from the school
boards Association
[Music]
thank you chairman Ladd good afternoon
members of the committee bear Christina
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association I'm from the get-go excuse
me um we're not taking a position on
this bill specifically
um I think the work that representative
cordelli put into the bill reaches um I
think a reasonable compromise with some
of the discussions that we've had in
this room going back the last I'd say
five or six years relative to the
withdrawal aspects for Cooperative
school districts the three-fifth super
majority I think is a is a is a
reasonable Safeguard
um for the you know for the community
that's looking to withdrawal but also
you have sort of the other Safeguard
where um a three-fifths majority Co-op
wide would have to have to um have to
oppose it so I don't have any specific
reasons for
um opposing the bill
um I don't know if we I mean we I don't
know want to go so far as to say we
support it because nhsba's position
um for some of the newer members and the
older members are going to get to
committee repeating myself I still think
that we need a two year long study
commission to study RSA 195 and it's in
its totality even if we amend the um the
withdrawal process to make it
um easier or a little bit more balanced
excuse me um you know we still have
remaining questions about the divvying
up of assets and the dissolution of the
assets and who owes what upon withdrawal
and who gets the books and the and who
owns the building and things of that
nature so
um the the proposed bill I think is is a
is is a reasonable compromise to some of
the proposals that we've had coming
across this committee the last couple of
years but we still think studying the
the totality of the of the statute um
makes the most sense so with that I'm
happy to happy to answer any questions
are there questions of Mr Christina
not seeing thank you very much
are there any other cards on 5 30 or any
of the others who want to speak on it
with that I'm going to close this
hearing
do you have a copy of your testimony
foreign
did you hand any to the committee
okay where'd that one go
Al
s
okay we got it
I got the I got the Court ruling on it
at my house on what you guys went
through
yeah
yeah I know it
well boy they can change that valuation
on you you're going to be paying big
bucks
pardon me John
please
foreign
if the committee will
take their places I think we're ready
for the next bill which is House Bill
466 relative to water bottle filling
stations in schools and uh chairman
ricklette is ready to introduce the Bill
thank you very much for the record my
name is representative Rick Ladd I come
from Haverhill the Haverhill New
Hampshire at the Haverhill Massachusetts
and uh here to introduce this bill about
water bottle filling stations in our
schools as you'll note this is a very
short bill has four lines in it
and what it does it subtracts the
eliminates deletes the rule making
process necessary that's associated with
the bottle filling stations which we
pill uh in the schools which we passed
last year
basically what the issue is that there
is
um there's no need for rule making all
they have all the doe has to do is ditto
what is in this bill here it's similar
to when we passed legislation for
embedding mathematics into the fourth
course at the high schools we never had
rulemaking for that all we did is take
the statutory language and that's the
guidance all the guidance that the
department needs and it's all that the
school districts need as well so
um the department feels that there's no
need for these this rulemaking I concur
it's nice to see where we don't have to
Pat make more rules and so with that I
will conclude my testimony thank you
questions uh representative flakis
thank you so I just wanna
make sure I understand
what we passed regarding water bottle
filling stations and new construction
and all of that stands it's just the
rule making part of it that is going
away and all the policy Remains the Same
nothing in the policy that we passed
last year is changed at all
for the questions
see none uh thank you you're welcome
thank you
thank you very much
we we have no other cards
um
anyone from the audience we're
collecting cards no okay
thank you very much
um our shortest hearing of the day and
uh we have until 3 15. oh wait a minute
no okay
uh Mr ranking uh are we good with it
yeah okay I'm gonna pass the gavel off
to reps and cordelli
we will uh enter into an executive
session in this case since there was
agreement on both sides and
um I call upon representative lad for a
motion
from representative miler
um
no further discussion representative
Miler no
um yeah
uh the clerk is uh preparing for the
roll call I think
um
all set
uh a call upon the clerk for the roll
call in that case
it's uh Hospital 460 relative to what
house bill 466 relative water bottle
filling stations in schools
or 66 466.
House Bill 466
ready to go all right
representative cordelli
yes
representative Lucas yes
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher
not here uh not voting
representative dry yes
representative McDonnell yes
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
uh representative corticello is not here
representative Miler yeah
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall
yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden is absent
representative
Damon yes
and representative Ladd yes
yes
17-0
um is everybody fine with the consent
calendar yes great thank you
okay now I have received from a member
of the committee for reconsideration
um on a bill which dealt with the
the statutory books which we receive
here
um so we do not have to declare an exit
we can just continue now reconsideration
we can take action or if if you would
like if you're not prepared and you're
prepared
um
are we prepared from a clerical
positions knowing how you okay uh we'll
walk through it okay
well that's right
okay so all I'm going to do is just give
you a notice that we will be executing
this bill at our next exec we cannot do
it willy-nilly like we did in the past
years
this is the book Bill we're going to
have to do it when we have a day notice
for executive sessions that we can pop
it on and we can take care of it so we
won't be doing it now this one's okay so
the first one yeah the first one we can
do it because that's immediately
following the bill we just took up so we
can do that
that's right yeah yeah
it's that crazy rule
okay so what we are we're at uh so we're
at a recess until we have to do the next
bill
at 3 15 another 20 minutes from now
thank you
yeah but before we start out any further
I want to say what we just did with 466
we can't do
and and the reason for that we used to
be able to exec bills immediately
following the hearing of a bill and just
even though this bill was such a simple
thing done in about two to three minutes
the whole thing hearing an exact session
on water filling stations we we just
can't do it we have to and and the
reason for that any bill that we have
already scheduled for an executive
session in the future you cannot exec
any earlier than that however so and and
even though we had agreement between the
ranking member and my myself on what we
did and we had a unanimous Road 17 zip
we can't do it so we're gonna have to
wait and come back and take another two
or three minutes on a day we have
exacting our bills so so what we did is
kind of Moot and it's not going to have
any bearing on what we did so we just
have to replicate our efforts at a later
date
and it was a dry run for the clerk thank
you for your
understanding
okay we're going to go ahead uh we're
ready for the next bill it's 4 40. it's
relative to the education trust fund and
represent Glenn cardelli is the sponsor
he's ready to go
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
colleagues uh for the record again Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro
Wolfeboro and Ossipee and uh this is
House Bill 440
relative to the uses of the education
trust fund
and it updates RSA 198
39 which established the education trust
fund and is used to define its uses
over time
we had
things to the statutes and maybe don't
cover all the bases and in a number of
cases one base that has been missed is
the education trust fund statute and its
uses
this bill adds into that statute uses
for the trust fund that have been
defined elsewhere in statute
but should probably be added to this uh
section of law as well and that's the
intent of this bill in working with the
Department of Education to identify
those areas of law that need to be
reflected here
um
I handed out earlier if you have it a
sheet that underlines certain sections
certain
um phrases in the
statute to those reflect the additions
to 198.39 this was drafted as a repeal
and reenactment so they didn't capture
or highlight the additions up to the
bill so I tried to underline them for
you in working with the Department
um but as you go down certain things are
added for instance on line eight to
distribute kindergarten grants to
municipalities and school districts
pursuant to 198.48c
down in a line
um
15 distribute grants for at least space
to approve charter schools pursuant to
198 15 HH these are all things that have
been placed in statute they are law
but
and they are allowable uses of the
education trust fund pursuant to those
statutes but should probably be
reflected also in this um section of Law
related to the uses of the trust fund so
this tries to clarify that and clean up
those sections of law that do utilize
the education trust fund so that in this
one section of law you get a full
picture of what is coming out of the
education trust fund
um and that is the purpose of this bill
and I thank you for your time
are there any questions of the
representative representative Tanner and
then representative leckis thank you I
think um
one of the important issues in this is
that in that Preamble it says that's uh
money's in such fund shall not be used
for any purpose other than to distribute
adequate education grants to
municipality schools districts and to
approve of charter schools pursuant to
198 uh colon 42 and then with some other
things isn't there a lawsuit that's
currently currently being uh worked
through the courts on this particular
issue and if it is
um should we vote on this
in lieu of the fact that it's already in
the courts
um I don't know if we should delay
legislation to clean up our statutes
based on any pending lawsuit I don't
think it really impacts the lawsuit at
all
so there could always be a lawsuit
hanging over us in terms of pending
legislation so I don't see any reason to
delay this this bill
further questions from the committee yes
representative leckis
thank you this is another one of those
just to make it clear
I want to make sure what you're saying
is that all of these things are already
passed in law and already say will be
drawn from the education trust fund
and so all we're doing is
listing under education trust fund all
the things that we've already passed and
said can be drawn from the education
trust fund is that correct and that is
what I'm saying and I think
if you choose you will hear from the
education department to verify that
thank you representative Woodcock thank
you chairman uh representative thank you
very similar to representative's
question where were these paid out of
prior to this they
thank you for the question they are all
are already paid out of the education
trust fund because in uh for instance
198 15 HH it says it is to be taken from
the education trust fund but when that
statute was passed that law was passed
um they didn't go back and put it into
this section of law so that is what
we're trying to do here okay yes sir
thank you so just for clarity every one
of these uh uh statutes that represent
Lucas just spoke about everyone's
identified here online here currently
being paid for Education trust fund
um that is my understanding and I think
that the department can verify that for
you thank you thank you Mr chairman are
there thank you are there further
questions from the committee
thank you very much
like to have David Trumbull
good afternoon good afternoon thank you
for having me and thank you for all your
time I know you all worked very hard and
you're probably happy to be at the end
of a long week
um I am opposed to this bill my
interpretation is a little different
than what you just heard I think that
you started I'm specifically interested
in the education Freedom accounts aspect
because that's listed in this bill is
one of the things that would be
permitted to be funded through the
education trust fund and we started two
years ago with it as a pilot project and
under this bill you basically would have
a blank check for the education Freedom
accounts in the handout that is
available to the public it says that um
a transfer from the state general fund
is required to bring the balance to zero
whereas if you use up the entire
education trust fund you would then go
to the general fund so basically if you
spend more in the education trust funds
then and the education Freedom accounts
then is in the education trust fund you
would would just go over to the general
fund and continue to spend so you're
basically putting a blank check on the
education Freedom accounts it could be a
hundred million dollars and even if the
education trust fund doesn't have that
much money you are passing a law that
would say it would now go over to the
general fund and you could spend with no
cap whatsoever so I think that's not
we're not ready for that we don't have
any data in this state that this bill
actually works so I think it would be I
would be hesitant to support that
uh in preparing I was looking at some
research on the education vouchers Diane
ravich who was was once the U.S
Secretary Secretary of Education under
George Bush the first George Bush she
was quoting Josh McGowan a professor of
Michigan State University who looked
into vouchers and he said that
large-scale studies in DC Indiana
Louisiana Ohio show that for kids who
left Public Schools harmful voucher
impacts actually met or exceeded but the
pandemic did to the test scores so we
all know how badly the pandemic affected
public education the long-term effect of
vouchers was even worse and he went on
in his statements to indicate that once
you get past the Pilot State pilot
program phase of the vouchers the
effects are even worse so I would
hesitate to see our state make this kind
of a commitment financially I have three
major points first is the financial
accountability second is the educational
accountability and third is a civil
rights question so on the question of
Finance accountability as I said I feel
like this bill provides No Cap
whatsoever these accounts could end up
going on indefinitely with no limit
there should be a limit as to how much
money the state is willing to spend on
these bills the general fund right now
does have a surplus obviously everywhere
around the country if you look it up
a record number of State surpluses
all-time high but even the Pew Center
was just saying there's a cliff coming
now whether or not that's this year or
in two years the cliff is going to come
These funds are always cyclical if you
set up a program and then you don't have
funding for it in two or three or four
years the educational impact on the
children of the state who are now
counting on these programs and it
wouldn't be funding for it would be
disastrous it would be Reckless to
financially invest in a program that we
do not have a specific set funding
dedicated funding source for second is
the question of educational
accountability as I indicated that one
study indicated that vouchers have
failed the Stanford Graduate School of
Education Professor Martin Carney booked
the 25 years of data and he said that
they have failed around the country and
he said there are better ways to invest
our money teacher training Early
Education after school programs things
that we know work when we've looked at
the voucher programs around country
long-term studies up-to-date studies
they are not effective so why would we
take a huge gamble when something that
we're not ready for we built this
program on basically with hardly any
foundation for it pilot project now
we're building a five-story skyscraper
you need to have an adequate Foundation
if you're going to build a tall building
that means you need to have some
educational accountability does anybody
have any test results from any of the
children who have been in the voucher
program so far comparing their niwa
results before and afterwards we don't
if New Hampshire is going to have the
same results that we've had around the
country why would we want to give a
blank check to something until we know
that it actually works now I've heard in
the paper that we don't need to have
education or financial accountability
because who knows better where their
children should be at than the parents
that's all the accountability that we
need but if that's true then why don't
we have educational Freedom accounts for
all the children in the property poor
towns there are tens of thousands of
these children out there if we trust
parent with money let's give every one
of them five thousand dollars they can
build Wi-Fi in their home better
computers take their family on trips
hire tutors whatever they want to do if
you're not willing to actually spend
money and give it to the school
districts in Claremont and all these
other towns that can't raise enough
money locally to fund their schools but
why not give five thousand dollars to
every parent for every child in those
schools first and if there's any money
left over then give it to the parents
who can afford to pay their property
taxes and send their children to a
private school put them at the end of
the line don't put those people at the
front of the line put them at the end of
the line give this money to the places
who need it first if you really trust
parents and that's all the
accountability that you want you say we
don't need accountability they give it
to the people who really need it because
they have a demonstrated educational
need the third area is civil rights
accountability I was looking up some
legislative history comments just to
find out exactly what it meant and it
was a Oh here it is New Hampshire
Supreme Court case Justice Duggan wrote
this decision and he said if a statute
is ambiguous we consider a legislative
history our goal is to apply statutes in
light of the legislators intent in
enacting them in light of the policies
sought to be Advanced by the entire
statutory scheme this bill is about
finances I understand but there's been a
raft of bills that would expand
eligibility for the for the education
Freedom accounts
the question is are these Public Schools
or not now when I was here last week
um
Mrs Kate Baker Demers who is the
administrator of the scholarship fund
who's really thought that the only
person in the state who runs this
program because the Department of
Education doesn't run it I know there's
a bill to make the Department of
Education run it she testified that she
sees these programs as quote part of
public education system and its public
education and infrastructure so the
people who are running the program see
the vouchers and the money that they're
going to and sixty percent of the money
that's been spent has been is direct
tuition to private schools she sees them
as part of the public education system
in New Hampshire to me that's
legislative history so these education
Freedom accounts are now public actors
if they're Public Schools they should
have to follow RSA
193.38 that no person shall be subject
to discrimination in the public schools
now the basis of race sex gender
identity sexual orientation disability
if we are going to give money to people
to pay tuition to go to a private school
for any private school that wants to
receive that money should in turn tell
the state we will follow State rules and
regulations like all other public
schools because now we are public
schools as part of the legislative
history and that would also mean that
you can't tell people when you go to
these schools you have to sign away your
right to a quote free and appropriate
education under Federal special ed laws
what happens is that children need
education special ed services every
single day but if they go to a private
school they don't get it now maybe they
can take the five thousand and buy some
extra tutoring after school but they're
forfeiting the rights to special ed
every single day all day long in those
schools if these schools want to be
considered part of the public education
system they should just simply agree to
follow all applicable state and federal
laws in the state no discrimination on
the basis of disability also I would
mention lgbtq rights because there's a
lot of religious schools that prohibit
people who are lgbtq from teaching in
these schools if you're a married couple
regardless of your child's status you
can't bring your child to those schools
and if you're a child who identifies as
lgbtq you cannot attend these schools
that would be in contravention to RSA
19338 no discrimination on the basis of
gender identity or sexual orientation so
is New Hampshire really wanting to give
five thousand dollars to parents to send
their children to schools that
discriminate against members of the LGBT
community now obviously they have the
right to do that under religious freedom
but the question is do we as a state
want to spend our money
supporting that or should they have to
follow at a minimum State rules the last
group that falls into this is the home
school category and I realize they're
not really technically homeschool now
they're EFA students but at any event
the question is when does a school
become a school there was testimony last
week from somebody who has a a learning
center and dairy and they had like a
hundred students on their roster and she
said any given day they have 40 to 60
people at their school right to me that
sounds like a school so I looked up at
the Department of Education website how
many small schools are there in the
state and there's 50 between the talent
schools and the charter schools 50
schools that have 60 or less students so
being small does not mean that you
aren't a school you are still a school
so I think now look if two families are
doing homeschooling together this week
you take my kids to the museum next week
they come over to my place and we do a
project that's not a school but when you
start getting up to 12 people and you
have a building that you're going to
every single day to me that's a school
so I think if you want to be getting
money from the state shape and acting
like a school that you should have to
follow the rules of being a school so if
you want to pass this bill and all these
education Freedom account bills I think
the prudent thing to do is to lay down
the structures in place put Financial
accountability in place put educational
accountability in place and put civil
rights accountability in place don't go
passing the tail end of the bill before
you've built the foundation on the house
so that's all I have thank you thank you
very much are there any questions
representative McConnell thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
for being here
um from what I understand when I read
this bill and as it's introduced it's
more of a housekeeping bill so your
testimony differs so I'm just curious
for clarification from your
understanding you said this as you put a
blank check what this weighs the cap or
remove the cap that exists on freedom
accounts does this make that change this
bill If This Were to pass as reading
okay I don't think it changes the amount
of money that people would receive for
the for the accounts my understanding is
that the original passage of this bill
the last time was not done as an
independent act it was thrown part of
the massive budget so it didn't get
individual clarification and the lawsuit
that was referenced by a question I
think from representative Tanner is
about whether or not the education
Freedom accounts can use money from the
education trust fund which was set up
specifically to address adequacy and the
differences in in between the poor and
property poor and property Rich towns so
I don't think there is a legislative
directive that exists that says
education Freedom accounts should be
getting their money from the education
trust and I maybe I I you are more aware
of these things than I am but for my
reading is that coming into this session
that had yet to be established and that
there's a perhaps a goal now to make
that be something that's established and
I'm saying if you do that and then with
a little paragraph at the end that says
if you run out of money we'll just take
it out of the general fund that's where
the blank check comes in so again I
could be wrong and maybe this is not
directly applicable but I think that
it's a general comment on the education
Freedom accounts that we need to make
sure that these have these types of
accountability follow-up please yes so
to clarify just to make it abundantly
clear maybe the department could clarify
as well but as you interpret this bill
this changes the statute it doesn't just
clean it up yes okay thank you
further discussion or questions from the
committee
nothing thank you very much thank you
very much like to invite Deborah Howes
thank you
good afternoon chairman Ladd and members
of the education committee I'm happy to
be here again uh testifying in front of
you and I do have written testimony I'll
give you after try and summarize it
um
to my reading this is more than a
housekeeping bill it does change the
intent of the education trust fund
um I'm going to stick a little more with
a history lesson even though I'm a
reading teacher
um
New Hampshire has a constitutional
obligation to provide
a public education
that has been found it's written in our
constitution it's also been found
through several court cases that we have
an obligation to provide our children
with a public education families can
choose other options
but New Hampshire as a state has to
provide public schools and a public
education and fund it
um
State funding has not always been
sufficient or fairly distributed again
that's not just my opinion the court has
found that several times the education
trust fund was set up an attempt to
address this after previous Court
rulings
and it was limited to public school
students public schools and public
school districts
so although money may be coming out of
it that doesn't mean money should be
coming out of it for some of these other
programs
uh and there is currently a lawsuit on
that
when you start adding in programs that
are not going to public school students
public schools and public school
districts
you run into the potential for
difficulty because tax money is not
Limitless we all know that we all pay
property taxes
um and it's all coming out of the
taxpayer's pocket
so when you start running short on money
you are either going to be
shortchanging your 160 000 students in
public schools
or and I believe the voucher law was
written so that you can't shortchange
that uh the speaker before me I think
had that correct I don't have that in my
notes
um
or you're going to go back to the
taxpayers either at the state level or
through your local property taxes to
have them make up the difference when
you don't have enough to fund your
schools
so I am speaking in opposition to HB 440
it is much more than a husky being built
it is adding in a program that is not
currently
written into the education trust fund
and to my opinion and the opinion of my
4 000 members across the state uh it
does not belong there
we want to keep our commitment to public
education strong the state has a
constitutional obligation and we want to
see you meet that so that all of our
students have a chance to thrive and
that's my testimony thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
okay not seeing you thank you very much
uh Christina
foreign
members of the committee bear Christina
New Hampshire School Board Association
we are opposed to this bill
um I can't follow the first speaker
um we we Echo and support and reiterate
um everything that that first Speaker
said and certainly reiterate uh the
testimony from Ms house as well too
um I don't have the language in front of
me but nhsba has a couple long-standing
resolutions that we support public money
for public schools and we also support
um living up to its Financial
Obligations to support Public Schools
before it funds any other program I'm
going to save you a lot of time and
effort I'm not going to get into the um
you know the the merits of of the
voucher bill as this bill is not
relative to that but we oppose the bill
we support public money for public
schools we support the state fully
funding its um outstanding obligations
that it's been neglectful of the public
schools for at least the last 15 years
of not going back longer if you want to
bring adequacy into this whole
conversation as well too and with that
I'm happy to answer any questions thank
you are there any questions for the
school boards Association
thank you very much
is there anybody here on the committee
that's going to request information from
the Department of Education
so Caitlin are you available
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
thank you Caitlin for providing
information all day today
um just to clarify a question I asked
earlier to another speaker does this
feel as reading change statue or is it
just a clean up statute
there are there is one change
um to clarify that this bill does
let's see did I just want to double
check
so there is one proposal that is
included in the department of
education's budget
to include lease aid for chartered
public schools in the education trust
fund and move it from the general fund
that is a departure from current law and
current payment
um the Department of Education had
previously included that in our budget
and has been in our budget in the
general fund for the last I don't know
six ish years it's about 500 000 a year
appropriation
um and we suggested moving into the
education trust fund so the statute does
do that
um the majority of the language here
um is correcting
um or codifying existing practices at
the department can I ask a follower
please yes you may okay so thank you for
that and the change that you said was
relative to lease aid for Charter
Schools yes so there's no changes
relative to the freedom accounts in this
is that correct um I cannot specifically
talk about the freedom accounts as we
have pending litigation
thank you further questions
represent Cornell
thank you and thank you Caitlin and this
may have been explained and I may have
missed it but on the fiscal note one
percent to the Department of Education
for 10 million dollars to I guess
administer all of these is that
something new or is that all something
we've always done that is a request on
behalf of the Department of Education
yes okay thank you further questions
woodcock
thank you chairman
um
good afternoon I'm sure you'd love to be
here on Friday
uh thank you uh
when representative cordelli presented
this bill
um I asked them as did represent Lucas
if there's anything in here that was new
and hadn't been previously funded and he
said no everything's as it had been
um and you indicated that that's not
correct that the child school is not in
there previously
um
the question that represent McDonald
asked about the efas uh your response is
that is pending litigation so that you
can't comment on that which is which is
fine but in the presentation
representative cordelli indicated that
this bill he was doing it at the request
of doe
so
um so doe is knowingly putting this bill
forward with litigation pending is that
correct
um
Department of Education did put this
bill forward to request a codification
of current practices and an updating of
current law yes I do want to correct a
point that you had just said as far as
putting charter schools in charter
schools have historically been paid out
of the education trust fund as far as
charter school adequacy the only change
was the charter school lease Aid which
has not historically been paid out of
the education trust fund and the
department made that request as part of
our agency request for the state budget
okay thank you thank you chairman thank
you uh Caitlin I have a question for you
in the in the law book I'm looking at
194 F colon 11.
that's uh in the section referencing the
efas and its appropriation from the
education trust fund so it speaks to
this
it reads the amount necessary to fund
any grants or transfers of funds
authorized under this chapter is hereby
appropriated to the department from the
education trust fund created under RSA
198 colon 39. could you please explain
that
again I cannot discuss the EFA portion
of this bill relative to the pending
litigation
okay thank you
represent Luna thank you very much Mr
chair thanks again Caitlyn for for for
being here
um could um could you uh talk with us a
little bit about how the um how the
state
um budgets and um and appropriates I
guess for lease space to approve Charter
Schools
um which is now some new language that's
been yes
um so that process is there is a lease
Aid section of the law I think it's our
small it's reference right here or
whatever that is
um and so the process is is that the
Department of Education accepts
applications from Charter Schools
relative to lease-based I believe it's
on January 1st of every year
um and then there are certain categories
or types of things in the charter
schools lease for a space that we will
pay for and then we determine a
calculation and the department of
educational pay
the the lesser of
30 or 50 000 a year I it did just change
I believe worth 30 of the lease in total
to a charter school
um that has been appropriated
this is the third or fourth biennium
that this has been currently
appropriated to the department and
general funds
yes you may and so so and when you say
that that it's third or fourth year that
it's been appropriated through General
funds is that do you mean through the
budget process with a specific dollar
value yes yes and it is prorated right
now okay and then would would that
continue to happen
or would that would this now defer to
the education trust fund and as long as
the lease application follows the rules
prescribed in 19815 HH then
Appropriations would be automatic and
come from the education trust fund
correct we would change node well it
would still need to be appropriated in
the education trust fund but um but no
amount would need to be as long as it
qualified
um an amount would still need to be
appropriated um in the budget in the
budget yes
thank you
for the questions representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question I was just kind of comparing
198 colon 39
with the bill to see which cross
references they used in in that
particular chapter versus the other one
in and we've talked about some of them
but uh the one that says to distribute
phase out grants to municipalities
school districts pursuant to 194 f is
that currently being taken out of the
trust fund or is that out of the general
fund so those grants are established in
194 colon F which is part of the uh the
education freedoms account so I cannot
discuss that portion of this guy I'm
sorry yep
representative miler
thank you Mr chair I follow up to
representative Lino's
query
you said that there's there's the trust
fund
and there's a budget appropriation
so clarify for me since this now comes
under the trust fund this clarification
here in this language is notes that the
lease it from the trust fund how does
the budgeted proposal and the trust fund
work together and then my concern is
always trying to maintain as much money
in the trust fund to go back to Public
Schools as possible
so the education trust fund right now is
part of the education department of
education's operating budget we have
accounting units that are paid out of
the education trust fund right now
currently those include the majority of
what you have here in front of you
um what it concludes what is is included
in front of you here we have line items
for each one of those that is
appropriated in the education trust fund
and then the program is defined as in
law so let's
take the first section here so where it
talks about line four and five it talks
about Distributing education grants to
municipalities for public schools under
RSA
19842 so RSA 19842 defines the program
how the Department of Education is going
to distribute the funding and then
there's a line item that is an hb1
that's that relates back to that
specific section then you have something
like building Aid
and building Aid is paid out of the
education trust fund the law is
referenced right here and then there's a
line item corresponding in the
department of education's hb1 budget
that shows building Aid
um so when we're talking about programs
the laws around the programs are dictate
how the Department of Education
implements the program
so for example State special education
Aid which we just discussed yesterday or
two days ago we had talked about that
amount as prorated so
there's an appropriated amount for State
special education Aid in the in this in
the hb1 language
and if the special education costs are
to come over that we prorate that
because the law requires that we only
expend the amount that is in that line
item
thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you very much Caitlyn
have a good weekend
uh Louise Spencer
hi there my name is Louise Spencer I'm
sorry I had the time wrong for the
hearing so just making it in under the
wire here
um I appreciate you taking my testimony
so my name is Louise Spencer I'm from
Concord New Hampshire I often appear
before committees
um with my country Coalition hat on
today
um normally today I come with my
taxpayer
Community member hat firmly on to speak
against this bill in the most in the
strongest terms that I possibly can
I find the hypocrisy of this bill
really a challenge
it's from people who say that they both
support public education and at the same
time say they're not going to raise our
taxes well you can't do both things with
this bill
you're either going to take money that
would otherwise go to public schools
there by harming our Public Schools
without making that money up or you're
going to have to raise money raise extra
taxes to cover any money that you pull
out of the education trust fund to make
up the difference of public schools that
money that you're giving to the
educational
Freedom accounts that the vouchers
I find this particularly
upsetting given the failure of many on
this committee to support any bills that
would do accountability for that program
so we're pulling money out of our Public
Schools where there's so much
accountability
and we are putting we're going to allow
this money that is currently designated
for public schools to be given
to homeschoolers to private schools of
all kinds
we have a program that that
pulls 10 percent off the top as I
understand it to minister it
and we have virtually no accountability
as a taxpayer
I believe in paying taxes I think they
go to the good of the community I want
Strong's Public Schools I'm more than
happy to to do that
but I want accountability and I want I
want strong public schools and we know
one thing
you know
this Governor has said he's not going to
raise taxes he belongs to a party that
says he's not going to raise taxes what
that means is they're not going to raise
taxes in a way that people can see it
when they look online at the calendar of
the legislature or they look at the
bills that have been passed those taxes
will be paid and they're going to be
paid by property tax owners and sadly
there are school districts that can't
afford
to raise their taxes anymore to make up
this kind of difference so I'm glad I
made it in here
in time uh I thought it was at 3 45
because rarely have I
just found a bill
so
so unfair to our schools and to our
taxpayers so I thank you for taking my
my impassioned testimony
thank you are there any questions from
the committee yes represent McConnell
thank you again Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony I noticed that your
objections to this bill and of a lot of
the speakers have to do with the freedom
accounts do you have any other
objections to other parts of the bill so
if it were to pass with no relation to
the freedom accounts that just wasn't
reference at all would you have any
problems with a bill like that you know
I would have to quite honestly say I'd
have to look at the bill more in depth
that's the piece of it that really got
to me because I saw a program get
brought before you know in hearings like
this that was only going to cost the
taxpayers a couple hundred thousand
dollars per year and now we're going up
on millions and millions and millions of
dollars so when I see something that
would make it even more permissive to
spend money on that account on that
program that's what really got me to
drop what I was doing this afternoon and
run over here and
um so I but I'm happy to take a look at
the rest of the bill and I could get
back to you on that all right I would
appreciate that thank you thank you
further questions from the committee
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair um
hypothetically if a charter school were
to have to close
and a public school had to absorb those
students let's say double the student
population it would it be fair to
conclude that it would cost that public
school considerably more money to
administer that school with double the
population of students
I would think that would be a fair
assumption if any school that has
doubled the population of students
went along that same line if I'm sorry
if a public school were to lose half its
population because parents wanted their
children in a religious or alternative
education is it fair to suggest that
that would then cost the public school
less money to administer
no no that's a false equivalency
bringing more students into a school by
and large does increase the cost because
you have to add added infrastructure
however if there are basic requirements
that a public school has I had personal
experience with this of um you know my
daughter one year
they it looked like they were going to
be 25 27 kids in her class in all the
fourth grade classes a few more people
moved in to the district they had to get
another teacher the the public schools
have certain responsibilities to all of
the children in the community that's
what makes them valuable but when you
are simply pulling kids out and it you
know that would be a whole new day if we
are talking about removing half of the
kids from a from our Public School
System
generally it's a few kids here a few
kids there in these classes in those
classes but enough money that puts a
real strain on the school to continue
meeting the needs of the kids that are
there thank you
further questions from the committee
not seeing me thank you very much thank
you and sorry to keep you later then you
had intended thanks
okay I don't have any other pink cards
up here at this time so I'm going to
close this hearing on 4 40.
and that gets us to the end of the day
everybody have a good weekend
okay